the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
aggressive attacks were countered with
precise defense at the v-day candidates
in madrid spain blitz legend hikaru
nakamura pressed against tournament
leader ian nepomniacci but was unable to
land the decisive blow surprisingly at
the bottom of the standings chinese
superstar ding lorin keeps fighting but
has been unable to capitalize on winning
positions settling for another
disappointing draw will he be able to
bounce back and make a run round six of
exciting chess coming up next
[Music]
hello everybody we are now almost
halfway through this tournament but not
quite it is the 2022 candidates event to
determine the challenger to magnus
carlsen for the world championship match
to bring you all of this action we are
here in our studio in saint louis i'm
grand master alejandro ramirez with
grandmaster yasir sarwan alejandro as
always great to be with you and
christian calling all the action has
been wonderful thus far it really has
been very fighting games exciting chess
but lately not a lot of decisive results
absolutely interesting games indeed not
interesting results 11
of the last 12 games have all been drawn
so not many leadership changes
if any at the very top let's take a look
at our current standing ups absolutely
because that favors a certain yanni
pogbachie he's been leading since very
early by beating ding liran and he's got
this lead he actually improved it by
beating alireza in the last decisive
game that we had in this event he sits
pretty with three and a half out of five
fabiano carrano with three points is on
plus one and the only one half a point
away from nepal on fifty percent we have
jan shishtof duda richard rapport and
hikaru nakamura and in the bottom we
have kimura jabba ali reza first and
surprisingly dingley wren remarkable
let's recap how uh the round the
previous round all went
we had a very fun and exciting game here
between fabiano caron and richard
reporter crazy sicilian absolutely and
a5a4 by richard kind of really
shaking up the whole uh game it was
an exciting and creative game the one
that richard really excels in but fabi
calculated well and the game
unfortunately for fans fizzled into a
forced repetition and the game was
strong yeah just good good play
in the meanwhile pirusha duda what we
really could say about this game it was
bad prep right furuga seemed to just
fall right into a variation that duda
had already employed in a very important
game yep and first didn't have a new
idea and
got nothing as a result of his poor
preparation yes meanwhile hikaru
nakamura's preparation actually did land
him with a slight advantage from the
opening and something that became very
clear a few moves afterwards it seemed
that nepal was in the back foot but he
cairo could not finish him off well this
was one of those cases where you've got
this great advantage by hikaru but one
bad move
spoiled the whole broth
yeah meanwhile the same happened in
rajabov against dingley ran because it
was a fateful move 40 that dismantled
what had been a strategical masterpiece
by the chinese player and he wasn't able
to convert again dingley iran completely
out of shape not winning a single game
thus far in the candidates tough but
that's exactly what happened indeed and
we saw for lauren and
dingler and shaking his head absolutely
meanwhile let's take a look at our
format it is a long tournament 14 rounds
of chess it's an eight player double
round robin we have a classical chess
format for you guys 120 minutes for the
first 40 moves 60 minutes for the next
20 you get an extra 15 minutes when you
reach move 60 and a 30 second increment
starts ticking as well no drops before
black's 40th move and a half million
euro price pool and we've got uh the
scheduling pace we know what we're on oh
yeah it's three rounds of the rest day
three rounds and arrested which means
that today is our last day before the
second rest day tomorrow friday june
24th there will be no games wonderful
and we have christian in studio to
christian what are you bringing today
good morning yasser good morning
alejandro and welcome back everybody to
round six of the candidates tournament
to all the chess fans around the world
watching closely this exciting event we
had a lot of trills and spills but as we
enter the second rest day let's take a
look at the road ahead of the top five
players in the event we're going to
start off with one hikaru nakamura who
unfortunately for him missed a big
chance yesterday yesterday against the
leader yana pomnyashi today he will be
facing ding with the white pieces
tomorrow just before the midpoint of the
event he will be facing duda with the
black pieces and he will have an
all-american clash against fabiano
caruana in round eight but let's take a
look at the hungarian richie report who
drew all his games up to this point but
all of them were exciting battles today
he will be facing
rajabov with the black pieces tomorrow
after tomorrow excuse me a big chance
against the leader going into today's
round jan nepomnyashi he will be having
the white pieces and then yet another
white piece against yan shishtov duda in
round number eight and speaking of duda
the young polish superstar today he has
a big big clash against jan nepam
niyashi he will be having the black side
he will have to defend the black side
but we saw yesterday he's definitely
capable of doing so yesterday he had
absolutely no problems equalizing the
game against ali reza firuja after that
in round seven he has white against
hikaru nakamura and in round
eight he has black against richie
rapport
and one superstar hailing from the
united states that is fabiano caruana
today a big clash against the 19 year
old ali reza firusha who is struggling
he was unable with the white pieces
yesterday ali reza that is to get an
advantage he will be trying again today
with the white pieces against fabiano
caruana fabiano in round number seven he
will be having a big chance to score a
victory with the white pieces against
the struggling timur raj above and then
in round number eight a big battle
against his compatriot hikaru nakamura
with the black pieces and of course our
leader jan nepomnyashi going into this
round three and a half points out of
five half a point ahead his nearest
rival in round number six he will be
having a big chance white pieces against
jan shishtav duda in round number seven
black pieces against richie rapport and
in round number eight another chance
against another struggling player up to
this point white pieces against the
chinese dingley ran guys every single
day we have just amazing pairings i
can't agree with you more christian
absolutely and let's take a look at
today's pairings alejandro some of them
are
absolutely mouthwatering yes we start
with a game between teemu rajaba
richard rockwort is going to be a
creative game for short yep but take a
look at this one you were mentioning
hustle watering games ali reza firuja
who has not been able to prove anything
so far in the candidates right he has
white against fabiana corona we know
he's hungry we know he needs the points
absolutely cannot draw himself out of
the tournament but fabi's saying look i
also need points i'm not a point away
from nepo will he try with black hikaru
nakamura in another great game with the
march missus against ding loren a
softing lyran so far in this tournament
hikaru is looking for his chances uh
when you get white i mean
the the victories are slim but and
between slim and none
and finally we have another great game
the marquee match-up for me that's true
yana pognachi with the white pieces
against the very creative yanshi of duda
who repeats black today and if duda can
win
just like what nakamura could have done
yesterday that would
open up the tournament completely and
look at the head-to-head they really
haven't played that much no which is
quite surprising neptune versus duda
it's a 2-1 in favor of nepal with only
four draws all right and of course all
of these fighting and why are they
fighting so hard alejandro well there's
plenty of money in in the fight half a
million euro prize pool with 48 000 of
those going first place 36 going to
second 24th for third but remember that
you also get an extra 7 000 euros for
every point that they score score as
many points as you can score as many
points again but this all pales in
comparison to the big prize it's the
qualification to play magnus carlsen in
the 2023 world chess championship that
will be for all the marbles the crown
jewel of chess absolutely and as we get
started get ready for the start of this
round six i just want to say for fabby
fans
i mean today
is so huge
not only for his chances but if farouza
doesn't get off this lack of victories
uh
when
and if farouza when farouza wins it
can't just be that farouza is going to
beat timor or somebody in the last place
as well he needs to beat the guys who
are leading the tournament and to reel
them back in so
uh big big big clashes as we start this
round six and we're underway nepo knight
f3 d5 g3
and not his usual approach
well i i've seen him being
doing this stuff with c4 uh he does
transpose into cattle and type positions
sometimes remember that last year he
beat alexenko rather he's not last year
but the last candidates yes he beat
alexander rather easily from a catalan
position right in which the black player
seemed completely lost on what to do
yeah and that was really really early
too it was inside like
two dozen moves where the advantage was
already decisive
and i remember it was uh from the world
championship match between magnus and
vishy knight f3 d5 g3 and vichy
had prepared and played g7 g6
and it was really strange because the
more i was thinking about it i said
why hadn't
this move been so popular
in the decades past because it crosses
quite a large variety of plans that
white could try and it seemed to me to
be
quite a good move
for the traditionalists out there
c7 c5 bishop g2 knight c6 going grabbing
the center and in a funny kind of way
inviting
a reverse grunfeld
a tempo ahead for
for uh white or did you say catalan
after say e6 and i think both are viable
for black at the moment both c takes d4
knight takes d4 even e5 uh going
straight into a group will down one
tempo really
it's considered to be okay
wow
it doesn't matter not more than that
just barely but it's holding on at the
moment so going into the grunfeld
defense i think by a tempo you're
holding off yeah it's kind of like by a
tempo but i've i've seen some top
players uh go into this variation really
how how cool is that i i i would have
thought that of all of the lines of play
this would probably be the most
dangerous one or the most
provocative and especially against napo
who is after all a a big grunfeld
defense player absolutely play it this
way uh so we're there's a paul playing
yeah duda seems to be what surprised
perhaps by the opening choice because
he's a stock i moved to yeah
um
christian take it away please yeah no i
mean this is a big moment uh as you guys
were mentioning
but also
and i was trying to understand this
variation the line that alejandro was
mentioning taking on d4 take on d4 and
then e5 forcing uh matters and if i
remember correctly it's something along
the lines of queen to a4 in this
particular position and forcing
this type of um
this type of end game after bishop to g5
but i will have to dig deeper and see
exactly where we stand in terms of uh
theoretical discussion right now and we
do have another catalan
on the board that is in the game between
ali reza and fabiano ali reza showing
that
he's diversified his repertoire when he
didn't play chess for like eight months
almost and this is exactly what we're
seeing right now from him and we see
this early queen to d3 which became
quite popular recently queen uh to uh d3
a very interesting idea not queen to c2
not queen to a4 not castle allowing d
take c4 but immediately defending this
pawn on c4 and now it does seem like
there's only a couple of games one of
them in particular drew my attention and
that is the one between dingley ren and
anish giri from 2020 a very very
intriguing game that was let's take a
look b6 it does seem like this is the
typical response whenever you put the
queen on d3 i might as well create some
chances and threats by opening up the
bishop and um hinting at the fact that i
have this idea of bishop to a6 creating
the pin taking advantage of the
placement of the queen queen to d3 take
on d5 and this is how they played uh in
that particular game castle bishop to a6
queen to c to knight to d7 and then
black tried to go for c5 this is the
typical approach white is trying to take
advantage of the fact that for the
moment he has a dominating knight on g2
and a potential expansion in the center
via e4 so quite an intriguing and uh
complex middle game in this one but it
does seem like
right now after queen to d3 fabiano is
in deep thought so let's wait and see uh
if he knows how to respond to this
because we know fabiano always shuffles
his openings with the black pieces he
tried all sorts of like queens gambit
declines queen queen's gambit accepted
take on c for later on the viennas a lot
of ideas uh that fabiano brings always
to the table almost in every single
tournament he has fresh openings that he
essays now the question to that is
always how well do you know your
openings how much time did you have
before the event to practice these
openings to gain experience in these
openings and right now alireza is
testing him with this move queen to d3
quite an interesting approach guys um
excuse me uh christian uh we're we're
kind of tasered over here queen d3 we
didn't realize number one that has
become uh popular
uh because to our eyes it just kind of
feels a little artificial
yes yes and i guess
what are the records from my perspective
it became a popular because
i had to face it as a coach it was
actually blue bomb versus oparin as well
oparin being my student at the
university of missouri so i know about
the existence of uh this move that was
quite recently in 2021
october if i uh remember correctly from
the ground must be from the ground
yes from the grand swiss so i was
watching closely uh that game for sure
queen to d3 uh did come as a shocker and
then we started analyzing of course as
alejandro mentioned once you analyze
your students uh openings but then you
forget that
that's that's the way it goes as a coach
you know because you have so many
students and so many openings it's
impossible to know everything right
and if i could just
obviously uh when you see the queen come
to d3 just as you're shown it's like
your your your
eye is drawn to the idea of bishop a6
but equally i want to say because the
queen is on d3 if i could play knight
take c5 the the oops i got the wrong
position up on my board uh but if i
could play knight takes um
where am i here no no
yeah there you go uh if i could play
a in a catalan i want to play c5 i
always want to play c5 in a kennel and
if i could recapture on c5 with a knight
i'm usually very happy right so wouldn't
it behoove black to play for an early c5
and then go for
in case of a d4 take c5 capture knight
a6 now if you ever play knight take c5
you might just
go past past equality right into the
into the better zone uh what is the
like fobby is tanking right here right
now
and one is the
theoretically approved line for black
well both of those games that i
mentioned and by the way once again
there's only 14 games right
it has been played recently by top elite
level uh players nevertheless it's kind
of a fresh idea
c5 has only been tried once by
shuvallova paulina
young prospect hailing from russia with
the move c5 immediately attacking
the center as you mentioned yasser and
castle was the response in that one not
taking on c5 inviting the move knight to
a6 if you do that then you might
actually be worse right right that's the
best way to take advantage of uh the
misplacement of the queen on a d3 and
then in general
she responded with b6 it does seem like
b6 will have to come on the board at one
point or another so the way
both uh on ish if i'm not mistaking
against ding and my student operating
play the move b6 now there's a couple of
differences after b6 c takes d5 came in
both cases not allowing bishop to a6
creating this spin you don't want to see
that on the board and after knight takes
d5 blue bomb who is by the way
tremendous theoretician hailing from
germany he improved over this idea of
castle essay by ding he played the move
knight to c3 immediately that was
novelty at the time knight to c3 bishop
to a6 and uh the way this game went was
like this queen to c2 c5 immediately
okay trying to open up and this is
the main idea right right
you hit the queen on d3 you're getting
ready to hit the queen on c2 as well
open up the c file gather up on c8 and
try to put some pressure on the queen on
c2 so c5 castle knight to c6 and then we
had this uh crazy wild position bishop
to f6 bishop to g5 take on b2
this is where ali reza dug deep in
preparation for this game and try to
come up with new ideas new ideas ali
reza as well as his seconds of course we
know chaparrino we don't know who else
is in his team but nevertheless
they've definitely analyzed and tried to
improve on these two stem games and
let's wait and see what they're going to
be bringing to the table or maybe
fabiano will decide that look
i smell a rat i have a bad feeling about
where this game is going so let's try to
take alireza out of his opening
preparation as fast as possible because
we've seen once the opening theory
finishes for ali reza especially in that
game against jan he had big problems
against hikaru he did get the will not
winning position he did get a better end
game and he kind of outmaneuvered hikaru
unfortunately for him hikaru was just in
time one move uh in time to make that
important draw so
let's wait and see how this one develops
but is going to be a very very complex
and nuanced opening battle thank you
christian let's just jump quickly to the
game of t-more versus richard because
that game got really weird and by the
way
just to interrupt you really quick c5
was played
all right c5 immediately that is well
prepared
this understands the positions very well
right exactly yeah um
richard's been uh sporting a kind of a
time enough
sicilian for him though enough of this
berlin enough of this petrov somebody
needs to bring the sicilian to the
candidate and i just wanted to say you
know like sometimes you have a day of g2
g4s yes or g7 g5s you know like people
queen d3
i mean there's something in the water
everybody wants to put their queen on d3
out of the opening it doesn't matter
what opening you're playing you just put
your queen on d3 and it's all good
queen g3 queen g3 you tell me
when things start getting strange it's
already quite strange to me and i play
this variation i don't really know this
idea of queen d3 queen g3 without the
queen on c7 it's actually very common
with the queen on c7
okay because of the tempo
like if i had put the queen queen on c7
and then you got queen g3 and you say
this this is a common idea all right
because if you take on g3 and i take
with the pawn yeah i'm happy it's it's a
pleasant end game
hey rook is
developed looks let's find ways to close
to equality but that's it close to
equality it never feels like you're
fully equalized without the queen on c7
it's not a tempo now the queen being on
g3 is exerting a little bit awkward
pressure the the desirable knight f6
bishop e7 castles let's go complete the
development
it's a little bit harder
so black plays the move
h7h5 and says your queen bothers me i
want to
kick it away no i'm willing to play this
move h2h4 giving up my g4 square to keep
the queen
uh where it is d4
knight comes back
my gosh you know like as a chess coach
you sit there and you you're horrified
by your students
putting are you developing the queen
first
uh versus all the pieces are on the
first row this is a very strange looking
position to me um check this out knight
f6 uh gift me the pawn on e4
most people i think would very rapidly
or quickly play knight d2
and or bishop d3
e5
at all let's let's keep the confusion
alive and it's all theory e5 knight e4
queen f3 fury queen d5 bishop d3 bishop
before we're still not we still don't
have a novelty this is still following
the lines of maxima sherlock graf
against janne pomnyachi at the zagreb uh
grants us to wrap it i know that we uh
cast so many games sometimes we forget
about them right but this is one of them
yes including up to king f1 uh king f1
would be yes king f1 also also on the
board and f7 f5
on the board by richie like also queen
d3 queen g3 has not come as a big
surprise as richard has been blasting
out his moves this is all theory as they
say this is still following the game
of
mvl and nepo which continued here with
the move somewhat confusing with c3
c2 c3
not bishop g6 check which i think a lot
of people would be
eager to slap on the board
c2 c3 and if you don't mind how did it
continue and what was the result the
game entered in a draw okay long
hard-fought draw okay
c3 bishop c5 okay bishop g6 check king
d2 king d8 sorry
not e7 king david eight got it knight d2
bc bc and we've got this wild position
in which both kings let's be honest are
really bad yeah
i mean the only question is which one is
worse worse
somehow they eventually simplified into
an end game and
and it kind of nothing happened
remarkable wow
we're not gonna see that we're gonna see
the bishop g6 check immediately this is
the novelty of the game so certainly
something that rajabov and rajavo's team
has prepared because you can kind of
guess that this is the top game of this
line and not king d8 the and the game
you just cited but uh king d
seven played very quickly actually
wow what a weird position black is
i have i i i'm clueless as to how to how
out of it
the structure looks bad for black right
you have all these holes you have a hole
in g5 on g6 on e4 and c4 on e5 on c5 on
a5
i think you just need the whole board
is there any place i don't have a
weakness i mean maybe we should have
done it the other way right what is not
weak but it is not weak so why does he
have in return
um quite a bit of standard designer
activity right center maybe on a good
day e5 and
like you say white's king
is not exactly ideal it's not that easy
for white to play a move like g3 king g2
especially
the the one thing you probably want to
avoid is to
capture on d5 and somehow this mass of
pawns in the center could actually
become
quite decent
so
really a great strategical battle going
on there by the way also another game
that developed rather quickly was the
game between our number one seed uh
dinglerin as black against hikaru hikaru
has played this
djoko piano bishop c4 bishop c5
and
i've always kind of associated dingler
in
with e4 e5 very much like levon aronian
and i think
ding lehren
is uh
simply fantastic with the black pieces
against one e4 and he is very much a
player that relies on heavy preparation
and in this case he's never afraid of
going into very sharp joke pianos like
some players with the joker piano with
black they just kind of put their pieces
where they belong and figure things out
right tingling run isn't like that thing
lauren takes the bull by the horn says
this is the most sharp the most precise
the best move all the way down to move
20 even if it means sharpening up the
position this move queen b8 has become
so popular exactly it's not the only way
to play the the position you can play
knight a7 you can play knight e7 there's
other ways to handle this but queen b8
with the idea of queen a7 has become
pretty so trendy and earlier in the
tournament ding had a game where he put
his queen on a7 and then he played a5 a4
and then he put his queen on a5
yeah the queen kind of like circled
around and around and around and
eventually
after a lot of twoing and throwing
the game was drawn so instead of this
move uh d4 we had the other setups with
a closed position but was going for the
direct break with d4 okay a little bit
more of a rare line but as you can see
on your database that's been played many
times okay bishop b6 a4
and a4 is there just
pretty much to prevent black from
playing
a5 and queen a7 what he did against duda
so a4
okay rookie is a logical move
exactly and rookie three played
apparently we're following a game
between giri and
david anton guiharo from spain one very
strong player very close to 2700 if he's
not 2700 already right
uh queen a7 uh
well actually queen to a7 was the
novelty
in that game queen to b7 was played but
it does seem like the queen on a7 just
simply stands better creepy's here looks
like a mouse lit yeah it does it does
and in fact i was looking through the
variations of beat seven doing i was
looking through the variations taken
away
from queen to b7 after a move such as
rook to e3 you want to go back to a7 so
improvement this queen to a7 played
quite quickly uh by dingley ran knight
to f1 d5 and there are actually having a
titanic opening battle in this one and
they're playing fast so they definitely
are aware of uh the plans in the
position and i'm mightily impressed by
what hikaru has brought to the table in
this one we've seemingly ran against
duda have some problems in fact in this
joke of piano with queen two uh b8 queen
to a7 we've seen that game with a pawn
coming all the way to a4 and then queen
a5 queen back the queen was just not
finding it's a right spot losing a lot
of time which allowed white to get an
advantage in that game let's be frank
about it and that could have pressed a
bit uh better and i think this is what
hikaru
learned from that game hikaru studied
the game that duda
played against dingley ran and this is
exactly what we're seeing right now
we're seeing the improvements
based on that stem game
but dingli ren is well prepared
everywhere and he does seem to know how
to respond to different challenges and
this is exactly what we're seeing an
early d5 committing to the spawn
structure e5 knight e4 and now knight to
d2
hikaru is blitzing out his moves by the
way hikaru has like one hour and 56
minutes and 30 seconds
he hasn't spent anything i mean they've
already played 18 moves can you imagine
that and uh dingley ran 142 so he's
taking his time trying to remember the
theoretical knowledge that he has and
acquired over the years because i was
looking through the database and almost
at every single juncture the big name
that i'm seeing is dingley rent with the
black pieces after queen b8 dingley ran
every everywhere every single move that
we make dingley reindeer so he's a bit
of a sitting duck it seems like in uh
this particular opening nevertheless
just like maxime trusts his grunfeld
right he seems to be trusting his joko
piano knowledge with the black pieces
let's wait and see if uh that is in fact
a losing gamble by dingley rat well let
me throw down the gauntlet and say
gentlemen
i don't like what hikaru has done i
don't like what acara has done let me
let me break this position down you
don't
okay i see the rook as a rover rook a3
and the rook is going to come over to g3
and or to e3 so if you can get your rook
to g3 let me get rid of the arrows you
get your rook to g3 you go bishop takes
h6 and i get it splat
uh there aren't a lot of palace guards
over by black's king
on the other hand i'm thinking from
black's perspective black has the two
bishops
he would like to play c6 c5 and dissolve
his double pawns at a time at a time
let's continue and get to the game
position so now after the move knight d2
so what do i see
i see that this pawn coming to c5 uh
you know there's no d4 d5 i'm going to
play bishop f5 i've got the two bishops
i just don't see how this rook can ever
get across the board and be effective
now that the pawn on d4 is fixed a fixed
weakness this knight moves okay if it
doesn't attack the bishop bishop takes
d4 will hurt your feelings knight's not
moving rook's not getting to g3
i see advantage black
whoa whoa whoa yes sir help me i don't
get it why why why not i got the two
bishops if i play c5 this is where i
think we're headed okay if you do play
the move bishop to f5 please i th a rook
to e2 i don't really i don't trust this
move okay i i don't trust this move i'm
100 sure what the idea of it is i get it
you uh
cement the control over the pawn on f5
on f2 that is but knight to b3 seems
much more natural to me
try to stop you from playing c5 and if
you do at least i get to exchange a few
pieces okay let's go for it this is what
i'm looking at take take take take
and now i go bishop to e3 right do you
do you have any objections no
you're doing good so how is this
position is the question right because
we're going to be left with
knight on f3 against bishop on e4
okay bishop to e4 coming we're going to
exchange okay and now
my guess is that white is ready to
sacrifice the pawn on e5
and try to play compensation
on the c file against the pawn structure
and saying that this bishop on e4 is a
beautiful piece
but it's not actually doing much in in
the immortal words
are good for you
let's sacrifice the pawn on e5
let's try it out let's see where we
stand no but queen queen d4 doesn't
sacrifice anything because you have f3
at the end correct yeah so but queen d4
sorry
knight to d4
between b4 yeah queen to b4 and rook to
c1 we get this type of position right
wow it feels to me that black is playing
for the edge i mean i get it yeah bishop
f3 visually does look good right
now the question is does hikaru know
more than we do i hope so for him
managed to uh find some deeper ideas
that we're just simply not aware of at
this point
um
still in prep it does seem like it i
mean
he's blitzing out his moves there's
definitely something there christian
while i have you i had another question
i like the move bishop f5 very much sure
yes what happens if i take on d2 first
because they do yeah i think you have to
take with the queen looks kind of weird
yeah and then i play the same idea i go
bishop f5 and then maybe i prefer c5
or c5 immediately maybe c5 immediately
i'm not really sure which one i'm going
to play piano piano piano guys piano
piano
slow slow slow
my turn let him play let him play as
well e6
check this move out the idea is to
vacate the square e5 and allow the
knight to jump there right wow and
that's going to come with quite some
difficult strategical questions that you
need to answer as black
i like it and this is one of i'm sure
one of hikaru's idea
ideas in the position
if he takes on d2 and tries immediately
to simplify the position as you were
mentioning uh alejandro but i think
bishop to f5 will come on the board
let's
say e6 kind of cleared
oh
you don't have bishop takes d4 right so
i have enough time to play that knight
on e5 yeah this is the key right bishop
d4 knight takes c6 and this is game over
right that's a double attack you don't
have uh bishop coming to f2 because the
queen is nicely placed on d2 it wouldn't
work
if the queen was on d1 but with the
queen on d2 we defend everything and win
the game christian that's a really
really beautiful tactic but maybe
instead of bishop f5 which i agree while
desirable uh allows that e5 e6 break
maybe too slow yeah
maybe i just start with c6 c5 in that
uh position with knight takes d2 queen
takes d2 instead of knight takes d2
right no no include knight d2 and then
c5 queen takes d2
and then c5
yeah that that is an option as well and
now once again we enter those type of
very aggressive lines
right the rook comes across the channel
three then i can get behind it it says
plus g3 rook takes g7 queen takes h6
this is that i can get behind this all
right because again there's not a lot of
palace guards
it does it does feel like the center
doesn't matter when the rook gets to g3
i'm happy it doesn't matter right the
variations i was queen takes h6
comes here bishop goes to f6 queen comes
to h8 that's how you make the books but
not in the good way not in the good way
you learn this pattern when you're uh in
your first year of chess
i agree
wholeheartedly with that let's jump to
our a tournament leader
because after watching all the action in
the richard rapport game the hicaro game
the farouzia game with queen d3
our tournament leader faded
come on we've got to show some respect
here guys uh we left it
after uh g3 bishop g4
i always thought of by the way just here
knight f6 bishop g2 bishop f5 as the
london system but i have also seen them
you know bishop f5 to c6 but
what do you call it when they play their
bishop to g4
uh we're gonna ask tom our producer he's
got he's got the cheat sheet with the
opening from what i'm seeing it's called
the keras variation i did i didn't know
that it just that i didn't understand
that it's the keras variation do you
associate keras with this
variation not really but hey look i mean
if we're going to scribe
a variation with paul's name on it let's
let's uh this is a decent one um h3 and
i have seen many grand masters
voluntarily capturing uh this knight in
such positions when the knight is on f6
i think nowadays it's considered the
cleanest way to equality is to actually
give up the bishop on f3 say you did
waste the tempo with the move h3 i'm
extremely solid you're gonna have to
waste another tempo to bring the bishop
back from f3 to g2 right you take it you
come back it comes like after all of
that you've won the bishop but black has
a very solid position in the meanwhile
bishop h5 uh fine by duda and let's see
how
uh we got we got a kind of a
queen's gambit decline carls yeah this
is actually very specific
it can be it can become very dangerous
for black right yes this is a very
tricky position for black if you're not
familiar with it because
white is very close to opening the
center yep and you can see that black is
still not castled right and if that was
the only problem then that's great but
as you're pointing out yes sir this
bishop on h5 sometimes is suffering
potentially could get trapped
especially
here as g4 is coming with a tempo so 95
duda is
stopped 15 minute think already in this
move
and in the keras variation
what does the database percentage wise
who does it favor and why well let's uh
have christian join us on that one
because he's the man with the engine i
do see that it's been played before
before knight to e5 uh or after night
after knight e5 because 95 is indeed one
of um
the rarer variations in this position
from what i remember and i played this
position as white as well i was a bit
surprised that duda went into this in
fact bishop f3 does seem to be the
cleaner version at least recently and i
faced it as well with the white pieces i
wasn't very successful against that one
i was quite successful against this uh
partic particular structure and one way
in which you can play as white and by
the way knight to e5 came very quickly
so
that uh signals the fact that nepo is
very well prepared in this line queen to
b3 is what i knew to be the main line
the idea is that you target the pawn on
a b7 and
with the inclusion of c takes d5 e takes
d5 the opening of the e file is going to
allow me to go after queen to b6 queen
to e3 check
forcing you to go bishop to e7 of course
and now knight to h4
which forces bishop to g6
i will take this bishop at some point i
don't have to hurry uh taking the bishop
yet but at some point i will take it and
i will have two bishops and from my
understanding after analyzing this
position for quite some hours was that
white is just simply slightly better and
has the easier play you're just going to
get the knight to c3 get the queen out
of the way put the rooks on the central
fires and then slowly slowly build
your offensive on the king side with the
pawns and the two bishops so at least
you get the advantage of the two bishops
now he did not go for this one in fact
and by the way after c4 another
interesting idea
for uh black was to play
c6 excuse me um actually
it wasn't
precisely in this variation this is the
moment where black had another option so
knight knight to f6 don't start with
knight to f6 start with the move c6 now
you might ask yourself what is the
difference after bishop to e7 so once
again you don't start with knight to f6
you start with bishop to e7 you can take
take queen to b3 queen to b6 queen to e3
and
does black have any better move than
knight to f6 and transpose into the
variation that i just showed you and
this was actually a game that i played
against one elshan moradi abadi
in
las vegas in 2018 and i we got this
position now and i was like okay he's
going to play knight to f6 and we're
going to enter the variations that i
know and he
played this move knight to f8
now you might be uh asking yourself what
is the idea of knight to f8 the idea is
to stop
the action of the queen on the e file
with the move knight to e6
and then just simply develop with the
move knight to f6 castle and so on yeah
a very clever idea this bishop to e7
early bishop to e7 and knight to f8 and
i analyzed it and it did seem like it
gives black good chances to equalize
this but right now
after knight to e5 which was the
surprise not queen to b3 but knight to
e5 duda is under tremendous pressure he
thought already for an 18 minutes
that is quite a lot and you're facing
nepal who you know analyzed this
position
in and out well don't leave us hanging
what happened in vegas
what happened in vegas stays in vegas
yes
i i did uh i did win that game and i
actually won the tournament that was the
national opening in 2018 so that was a
successful
[Applause]
successful uh trip for myself to veg i
usually play very well in vegas actually
because i i i don't do a lot of you know
the usual vegas things what's your
favorite city
where you do really well
where you played and won it's funny
enough because i have also one in vegas
i won the national open and i've won the
rapid tournament as well there you guys
share the trophy
somebody bring it to your house
and so on uh we get a replica every year
i think yeah
who's going to win the tournament join
the conversation
as we have already made our picks
but
with uh the
round five in the history book so to
speak how did the odds change as to
who's going to win the tournament after
four rounds let's take a look at how it
changed with all draws remember that's
what we had yesterday well this is after
round four nepal had a 42 chance and he
jumps he jumps with a three points
because he had black and against a very
strong player he carlo nakamura
so currently it seems that nepal's
chances keep increasing and keeping
crazy remember the tournament becomes
shorter exactly and again 11 of the last
12
games have been drawn what's remarkable
to me
is even though we're only in round six
fabi and yan
have the lion's share
of the chances at a near what am i
looking at seventy percent that's about
right wow that's a lot that's a big
number i mean this
you can choose the field but those two
players currently uh uh dominate the
field
well a lot of things can change based on
today's games because that's the way the
tournament is going and it really does
feel like that not just on the number of
points but the way that the players
carry themselves i think nepo is getting
all the positions that he likes
favi's doing okay but he hasn't really
been able to break through and some of
the players that you see with lower
percentages they just haven't shown up
well drawing their way out of it again
an eighteen minute thing
actually
he did capture uh nepo's knight on e5
it's like one of those things you just
kind of really feel like you can't live
with this knight on e5 i'm sorry you
know white's going to play f4 very soon
and
then capturing the knight is going to be
less desirable so dude a bit uh
the apple so to speak just
took knight
to e4 and said okay do your worst
uh jump into the
shoes of nepo what has he intended
aleandro
i also feel the same about the knight on
e4 that i can't live with it right
i just don't know if i want to get rid
of it with knight d2 or
c3 or i don't know
sorry there is an argument to be made
for bishop before it's a very greedy
type of move
argument to be made for bishop e4
well i think we lost control
but i
let's take a look knight d2 was played
ninety two of course no no no no no
target the knight on e4 but don't give
one of your best pieces in the position
okay so 92 player does give black the
chance to play knight takes d2 i also
don't know if there's an option right
you could try f5
wow
i didn't think you weren't going i think
that was legal yeah f5 f5 inviting e
takes f6
my king's still in the center that's
okay i actually think it takes f6
wouldn't be too much of an issue because
i think with the knight back bishop to
e7 castle i haven't been be three quite
happy with that
well uh it's funny that we we've been
seeing the move so queen between the d3
to g3
then
um
pardon me christian had gone queen to b3
to e3 check
i mean again it's a day of let's bring
out our queen early but now there's no
more pawn on d4 so queen to e3 can be
checked by queen to b6 yeah that is true
i was playing just
with alejandro okay yeah to to try to
get in the early e4 break with the king
and then how much of a problem is if i
just simply take on b3
yeah
and maybe i have to start with actually
no i don't take on e6 because you have
only four because you have queen e6 so i
take there and i take on e4 and we
exchange everything just trade well i'm
depending on what you do right i'll
trade that as well
uh
okay that's that's probably a good thing
that feels a bit annoying i don't know
i'm still trying to get the zen of it
myself long castle long castle yeah once
i got made it why not
okay
because i i've got bishop f4 and bishop
f5 on my agenda and a7 is hanging i'm
i'm not worried the uh sir i'm not
worried um takes a bishop c old
understood cold calculation
zero calculation either way right
okay what are we doing
c5
bishop c5 bishop c5 nice move in fact
wait wait wait wait you guys are
bamboozling me right now wait wait just
one second
it's our jedi mind tricks
do i have bishop to b4 or like what do
you do author bishop before
bishop to you guys are trying to
bamboozle me i know isn't it terrible of
us i mean
we we we are
tough
tough
tough customers tough customers
i don't know it it's it's terrible it
looks like a strange i i don't believe
you guys
i still don't believe he's not falling
for our jedi mind tricks i don't know
why
we keep trying i mean like like
okay how bad can it be if i take on e1 i
think you're just lost yeah bishop takes
a bishop takes c1 bishop f5 check rook
d7 and i'm not going to go rook d1 or
rook take c1 i'm just going to go for
the attack okay no you're going to
update the bomb i think you take the
pawn oh my god
it's a bit of a threat it's true that's
a checkmate thank you
[Laughter]
i don't like it all right all right
second second let's do our little no no
no
no
it's too early in the morning guys it's
two early in the morning no that's right
no warning no morning
it's early morning uh days for us here
in st louis uh as we're getting started
this round six but i gotta tell you guys
i i love the start of the round so far i
like the positions there's a rich
uh smorgasbord of positions uh that
we're looking at and
well uh some some fun going on
by the way um
i just wanted to say in our
really a marquee matchup game between
hikaru and diglerin
the moon christian that you your
computer your engine
suggested should have oh
he did it wow and he played it fast so
yeah
definitely in his prep
this makes a lot more sense to me i
didn't like those variations that we
were showing with uh i want to say it
was knight b3
yes knight b3 encouraging c5 there was a
loss of tempo
christian i don't think you ever even
got a chance to finish your thought
about the move rookie two and why
reinforcements dismiss it of course i
mean this is
this is alien chess
to my eyes
this is the uh era of alien chess rook
are you kidding what why would you play
this move now
the big question is
how do you respond against
right can we play c5 c5 actually
then
they lost
knight h4 after knight to h4 that's the
same idea
knight takes e4 to come and then g3
yes yes and queen d2 and when
yeah yeah this is like rookie four as
well oh well you have one defender on
the king side let's just get you you're
just gonna die
wow
love it love it i love rook takes before
actually yeah that's that's very nice
too c5 is not an option now your
convincing thing is that rookie 2 is a
great move well done christian yeah yeah
alien hey lisa aliens play very well
well done uh chris littlejohn uh
second right we have to give him a shout
out as well rook d8 on the board rook on
a8 to d i see that that's the that is
that was actually the recommendation of
the engine as well exactly
um my guess is that once you play this
move c5 and we see this exchange on e4 i
take with the pawn and then the d file
opens
also it's asking a very important
question
what is your next move i get it you play
the rook to e2 you're ready to swing
this rook all the way to g3 but what is
your next well d3 he already played it
well he played knight b3 before the move
knight b43 could i play the devil's
advocate put the knight back on d2 for
just a moment you want to play knight h4
yes i mean guess what i've seen how i've
seen this movie i'll take on e4 okay but
that's the whole point right and i'll go
rook g3 like uh i think i think but i
don't think you're in time anymore right
you think of the bishop and the bishop
f2 there's no that's check so you have
to defend against that you have to get
the queen off the d file but then i just
picked the pawn on e5 and that defends
everything and then you're winning
nicely gotcha guys guys yes we have more
moves 93 and instantly dingly
c5 as if he knew the move he probably
does
he probably does talk about preparation
c5 on the board i'm assuming d takes c5
i think it's box right are they right
c5 was the top engine move and this is
the thing when you make top engine moves
your opponent probably has looked at
them exactly so we're waiting and we're
expecting right now an immediate answer
by hikaru
yeah which doesn't come well he might be
off the board for a second right it does
happen that they get a refreshment but i
would be shocked if he doesn't take on
c5 but just don't see another move and
how does it how would the game flare
after d4 takes e5
you take it back
tonight let's say right tonight i was
actually thinking if you can take with
the bishop you can you can take with the
bishop as well
taking with the bishop is also an option
i'm just looking at the more practical
approaches at least to my eyes sure
knight to d4
bishop to d7 you have to defend c6
square clear that's right yeah sorry oh
you wanted to go the other way and allow
them
right now and bishop takes c5
instantaneously played by dingley
tell me he doesn't have this prepped
he's got this practice he's got this
price he's got this i mean he spent
40 minutes up to this point to try to
remember maybe he's playing he does that
he i remember he did that again many do
many players have to recall everything
in their file yeah i really did this
against maxima sherlock super wild uh
italian
forces forced perpetual dingley run
finishes with like 15 minutes left on
the clock he's like yeah i was just
trying to remember
wow
um you i mean they're blitzing out their
moves
queen takes e5 on the board knight to d4
on the board we expect bishop to d7 um
why i don't have to cover c6 anymore
right so you want to go
well with the rook coming to c2 maybe
you do have to cover c6
and that's another reason why the rook
on e2 maybe is better placed than the
rook on e1
thank you
christian that's a really beautiful
strategic point i mean i thought the
move rookie 2
was one dimensional meaning
he was
he was
over protecting f2
but
what you just pointed out the variation
we have on the board rook on e2 to c2
taking control over the c6 square that's
a nice
uh
point that's amazing one of the reasons
i really rejected rookie 2 white right
back here is again because i felt it was
such a ugly looking defensive move that
you know has one purpose and one purpose
only defending the pawn on f2
now we jump ahead and we start to say oh
well oops that wasn't what happened it
was this bishop c5 that happened and we
start to say hey wow wait a minute now
this rook could slide over
to c2 with a gain of tempo
i i've really warmed up
to the move rook e2 a lot
and again we're in
move 22 and how fast have the players
blitz this out karu has spent less than
uh seven minutes to get to this position
less than less than seven and dingley
ran
is left with an hour and 18 so he spent
about 42.
okay um
and how does the engine
first of all are we still in theory uh
christian theory we
we left those planes a while ago okay
good uh no no no knight to d4 uh seems
to be leading towards this type of more
quiet position after bishop to d7 bishop
to f4 but we do have the presence of the
opposite color bishops and we do know
that whoever has the initiative in those
type of situations usually has a much
easier game right because you're going
to be unable to defend on the color of
my on the squares of the colors of my
bishop that is the dark squares in this
case because i'm thinking that white has
the initiative i'm seeing this rook
potentially if this knight and this is
the glue to black's position the knight
on e4 right now if you lose that if you
displace that then the rook is going to
come to g3 and then you're going to be
in big trouble right all sorts of bishop
takes h6 sacrifices are going to come on
the board you need to keep this knight
for as long as possible on e4 whenever
you're going to target as white this
knight with the move f3 well at least
that closes up
the third rank so
you need to be very skilled
how you're going to develop your
initiative as white and i'm sure hikaru
has some good ideas of how to do that
great all right excellent preparation so
far there by hikaru brilliant
brilliantly
seriously great stuff we keep a very
careful eye
on this game with our top seed ding
lyrin who is suffering
and needs uh gosh does he need a victory
but uh thank you for joining the
conversation we have a social media
question for us alejandro remember that
you can join us here on twitch on
youtube we are taking your best
questions also on twitter at st louis
chess club we have from youtube user
trevor smith what are the biggest upsets
in the history of the candidates
tournament
a couple of ones that just jumped
through my mind i remember but i believe
it was from the interzonal tournament
that david bronstein one of the great
big favorites uh from the soviet union
in the last round was playing a very
lower rated player and
lost and got knocked out of the
potential candidates
you know uh
but i'm thinking still i don't know for
about yourselves the yvonne chuck versus
vladimir kramnik
2013 i think that will go down in
history is really one of the most famous
but
uh christian
do you have one i i think the whole
round the whole final round
that 2013 was probably the biggest upset
that i've experienced at least as a fan
in my time right because not only that
ivan
who lost five games if i'm not mistaken
maybe not all of them on time but a
bunch of them on time by flagging in
that tournament right he won
against vladimir kramnik who was
battling for the spot to challenge uh
vishyanan and then magnus carlson going
into the event uh needing potentially
only a draw he didn't expect uh his
opponent he's directed opposing vladimir
kramnik to lose against evanchuk and he
was playing against whittler with the
white pieces he lost that game not only
that he lost that game but zwiddler just
completely dismantled him in uh that
game with the black piece so that's a
big offset as well and he still went on
to qualify and the rest is history right
so in my opinion at least to my eyes
that is uh one of the biggest let's say
upset as a round all together in
canada's history and then of course the
candidates that
sergey karyakin qualifies
he
one of the lower rated was he the low
one of the lowest rated players in the
candidates that year he beats fabi in
the last round that's right and becomes
challenger yeah
not bad
well but it was just such a great game
by sergey it was a great game you know
that you kind of say well he was a
deserving challenger it is difficult to
say of an upset in the candidates
because usually by that point that they
get to the candidates everybody is so
evenly mad as we see i would say more
not an opposite but a surprise for me a
surprise was a girlfriend
or skeleton he comes out of the
candidates uh
those were the matches the matches in
2011 in kazan right and
defeating grishock in the finals that's
right yeah i would say that it wasn't
i would call it an upset i mean boris
had a lot of rating back then right but
i don't think he was a favorite and
no a lot of people are surprised no out
of the the group of eight
that he qualified from
that
that was that was uh
that was uh
well done boris yeah i think a lot of
people uh
gave three
big names in kazan right because we had
kramnik we had chris
and we had aronian right we also had
rajab of the paolo of kamsky and
mamedyarov but i think the top three
were the most favorite right uh but
gristrok plays iranian on round one so
one of them gets to get knocked out
immediately right uh galfon goes through
mamadara if gelfand goes through kamsky
and beats chris in the finals
impressive
okay uh so those we think uh but maybe
we're overlooking something even more
obvious and again join us on the social
media we did have uh jan's game of duda
by the way knight d2
which seems rather straightforward
knight takes d2 and i remember
when i uh
growing up in chess there were so many
times
that the move queen takes d2 was played
that they even stopped giving it an
exclamation mark right they would just
they'd go queen takes d2 and it would
just be okay i didn't realize that they
gave them an exclamation mark that's
right and i was like a kid and i was
like struggling to understand
why why you wouldn't take with the
bishop
the bishop and then developed the queen
and usually the ideas behind these early
queen takes d2 was because the bishop
was going the other way yeah you would
be you would end up playing either b3 b4
bishop b2 and you go oh the bishop
belongs on b2 well in that case why
don't you take with the bishop then put
it on c3 and it would be anchored and so
on anyway just a sidestep there but
bishop takes d2 is played
you think we're still in nepo's
preparation are we in some different
world all together i'm not sure i see
the database that you have in front of
you and we've kind of transposed back
into a game of svidler and karjakin 2018
where could they have played 2018
tata steel apparently all right there
you go thank you producer
on that invite on zay holland uh bishop
takes d2
um
what about
uh the the position how do you how do
you like these apples it feels that
black is a couple of moves away from
being okay but he hasn't made those
couple of moves not yet and that if i do
get in
my pawns rolling or a very successful
break on e4 right that you might be in a
lot of trouble here as black exactly i
would see it as a sharp position
tempi dependent on whether black is okay
or are doing actually quite badly
and it really is happening in the next
two or three moves if you get in i don't
i'm not saying you will but if on some
marvelous occasion get in the move e4 as
well as f4 it might be game over
or as you were about to say if you could
get in bishop e7 castles bishop g6 and
nothing goes wrong you're already very
happy yeah
i think so too
but one difference though 40 minutes
behind the clock already and it's a
visual one that's clock time yeah
and again it's such a difficult position
also to handle right as you guys were
mentioning if you don't get in time
uh to uh stop f4 g4 f5 then you're in
trouble and you have to find the right
formation because
i was shuffling through the lines and i
was playing f5 or f6 trying to make
immediate space for the bishop this is
already lost
lost take on what by take on f6 and this
is completely shattering right you
cannot take with the queen because
bishop to c3 and as you were mentioning
yesterday you want to get the bishop on
the long diagonal right why not via c3 a
nice defended square with tempo it's
just too fast and you guys were showing
those variations with e4 opening up the
e file and then just killing the black
king and this is exactly what's
happening right now so
bishop takes d2 bishop to g6 seems to be
the best move in the position but what
if i just continue with f4 now the best
move is to lose another move with the
bishop and to go bishop to f5 not f5 by
the way f5 already allows y to in fact
build a nice advantage after king to h2
it seems like
not borderline winning
but a very very serious advantage
long-term advantage
remarkable exactly exactly remarkable
king h2 and i'm sure it's not the only
move right but the idea is that you get
off any sort of checks with queen to b6
or bishop to c5 and then we just play a
long term uh position i'm going to
actually push my pawns grab as much
space
and engage into some sort of a minority
attack on the queen side b4 a4 b5 at the
same time while i'm getting my attack on
this side you don't really have much to
do on uh the king side because once you
go h5 i go h4 i block you there nothing
to do and i just develop slowly my
attack i have more space and this pawn
on e5 is such a good asset for the
position
that with that variation christian there
you're showing where black goes bishop
on h5 to g6
and then on g6 to f5
i don't see a lot of talent
he's going to spend 40 more for me 40
more minutes on that alone wow so
strange right uh that is yeah that i
can't imagine anybody finding that
actually g6 yeah the games that have
gotten please position uh all went
bishop c5 which in my view
is very logical of course developing
that pawn on f2 before i get the chance
to play a four exactly yeah
and how did to get those games kind of
uh result we had a queen b3 with a queen
c2 and we had a short castle uh sorry
shortcast looking aged i don't know why
i said that queen b3 queen c2 and king
h2
bb3 queen c2 and king h2 have all been
seen before bishop c5 is on the board
very human very human move i think so
too
so now let's say rook to c1 and let's
see if uh jan did indeed prepare deeply
this variation
a good novelty right now
sorry the idea is clear right you want
this bishop after that the a3fa diagonal
because if you managed to do that bishop
to b4 you'd never castle on this side
you're lost clear you cannot allow that
yeah so what you have to do after rook
to c1 or queen c2 for that matter with
the same idea attacking the bishop
trying to get it off diagonal you have
to defend it with queen to e7 okay okay
and now this is the position how do we
continue developing our
initiative on the king side so i guess
by the way to h2 once again a very
normal move natural move exactly get off
get up
play f4 next play f5 push your pawns
push them baby yeah baby yeah that's
what i'm saying
chess is about having some fun and uh
it feels to me like white is the one
having the fun you're a fun industry
right i mean you get to
push them yeah yeah well well
our number one seed is probably you know
pinching himself saying i'm in first
place i have a plus two result and i'm
really liking what i'm seeing here
uh as white
whether it be rook c1 by the way or
whether it be
king h2 and i'm probably more
prone to playing king h2 because i want
to play f4 and also the reason why i
might not want to play rook c1 is
because queen c2 exists right exist
getting the queen off of the diagonal
with a tempo so that i could play for e2
e4 in short i
like white's position and i think dude
is going to be challenged to
hold his opponent back jumping to the
game of ikaro and by the way here are
the
uh standings
and yan good thing about running away
with it would remember he is playing
with the white pieces a victory
and he's playing against him a near
rival and you're right two and a half
points let's take a look at that road
ahead we'll be playing with the black
pieces tomorrow against ritual report in
a very important round as we close down
the first half of the event and exactly
we start repeating opponents he'll be
playing with the black pieces i'm sorry
he was playing nepoist with white
against loren exactly repeat of the
first cycle where nepa won with black
against ding lorraine to send the number
one seed spiral spiraling downwards by
the way in the game between hikaru and
england rin
both players blitzed out their moves
like
well hikaru more than a ding let me let
me correct myself
i wanted to say after bishop f4
now even a deeper thing
than
than before for ding as he is looking at
this but i
is there
does he have a choice other than queen
b6 i'm thinking he has to play queen b6
i could just play but rook b8 is the
move rook b8 you just played rook d
uh
a short while ago he blocked my pawn i
can remove my okay rook i'm not sure
it's a good move i just think i would
think about it well i was thinking that
rook c2 and e6
is something i would be
fearing so if i go rook c2
tickling the pawn on c7 if you drop back
now you put your rook on b8 and that was
why i was
thinking that you needed to
avoid
uh that tactic well you can miss me
the jedi mind trick is really working
good morning ah but now
uh after rook b3 your your rook on e2
needs to be on e1 you're attacking the
queen is not defended yeah the queen is
not defended here and bishop takes a4
could turn the table suddenly oops
uh yeah so queen b
uh jumping christian uh did uh
did
why is dang in a deep thing
that's a good question
uh i'm not sure i guess hikaru is
playing jedi mind tricks on him right
now uh but bishop to f4 and as i was
mentioning look the engine is saying
zero zero zero but it's not an easy zero
zero zero right because you make a bad
move
with the opposite color bishops on the
board you fall under a tremendous attack
and then you never recover right right
this is what hikaru is looking together
get a longer middle game in which you
can pose problems for your opponent
practical problems because
i understand ding probably has seen this
in his notes but
for how long does he remember up to this
point after this point right and this is
the big question that hikaru is asking
right now queen to b6 does seem to be
the best move and after that of course
not rook to b3 the move that you guys
were mentioning but let's
increase the pressure in the center with
the move rook to d3 knight to c5 sure
are you sure you want to play that move
knight to c5 allow my rook to go to g3
right i'm 100 sure i will give you that
pawn on a4 glass dangerous if i managed
to get an attack on this side
would it go after knight c5 rook g3 and
just 94 back
94 back that's probably the best uh the
the pro probably the best path forward
and you're trying to take advantage of
the fact that this queen on b6
actually defends
the very important h6 otherwise i would
have rook take c4 take on e4 and bishop
takes h6 right right i still have an
attack even in this position i can
continue with queen to h5 it looks it
gets murky
but it does feel like with very precise
play black will be able to
to stop the attack and at least force a
perpetual
if you get greedy and take on d4 yeah
good luck
thank you very much
take my pieces all of them
except these two that are going to give
you the checkmate if you go on the g
file queen g5 queen g7 if you go on the
h file bishop g5 bishop f6 and there is
no way to defend against checkmate once
again that pattern that we've seen
uh a couple of moves as well a couple of
moves ago
very intriguing position
let's wait i've seen this i'm trying to
remember exactly when was the game uh i
think it was hikaru versus mvl it
happened in saint louis and i think it
was a rapid and blitz event in which a
very similar position arose from the
djoko piano
and it was i believe mvl that sacrificed
upon hikaru was with the black pieces
and got a tremendous attack very similar
attack to what we're seeing right now um
also an exchange sacrifice at one point
i will remember that game i'll do a
blast from the past later on okay
uh sharp sharp uh middle game but
i think it's that time for a commercial
uh break uh what's happening with q
boutique these days well today we have a
2022 gct limited edition t-shirt for you
you can buy it at qbtstl.com
you actually see a bunch of grandmasters
wearing this around yes the central west
end during tournament time and they're
staying at night they do stand out it's
really nice to have this uh tanks with
all the places that we have the gct this
year remember that we started in
bucharest we went on to warsaw and we
will continue with zagreb and in saint
louis remember zagreb will be joined by
a certain magnus carlson well
welcome welcome welcome welcome
when we go to a short break we have four
exciting games with us already and we
will be back to cover all of them in
just a few minutes
[Music]
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
ascension
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody we are in round
six of the 2022 candidates tournament
and it's still yanni pognachi that sits
pretty at the top three and a half out
of five we have no results today so far
fabira caron is on his heels but he is
playing black today against alireza
perugia
alejandra i gotta tell you i love all
four games even though
a lot of people may say well the farouza
versus
fabi game not too much is happening
i will just disagree and say that
thank god we're not seeing four berlins
right for berlin ending you know and and
we have a very very rich
assortment of games
how rich well let me show you let's
start with richie rapport and timor
rajabov timor rajaba the players kind of
blitzed their way to this position
don't get me wrong i mean that seemed to
mean like timor and
richard
with the queen g3 variations pretty much
said yeah this is my homework and this
is my homework and this is my homework
and then stopped
yeah long has been this thing it it very
long actually i think that teamwork took
30 30 minutes more or less to play the
move bishop g5 okay
and then
that was answered with a 17-minute thing
by ritchie f8 rook f8
which was followed by
a not so long eight minute thing for
timor rajaba flings the move c3 and
since then richie has been tanking he's
currently been thinking for just about
12 minutes
so
definitely a complete deceleration in
this game right right there's like wiley
coyote
backtracking and if uh i was working
with a student and i took black king off
the board and i go okay to my students
you've got this position as black i'm
going to give you the king where are you
going to put the k and i'm hoping that
you know all the talented ones will put
the king on g8 it looks a little bit
strange that the king is free-floating
on d7 what's up with that it's a very
strange position because the king on d7
is seems like such a target but white on
the other hand specifically the pieces
that would bother the king which are the
rooks
are not getting there
anytime soon right okay meanwhile black
has
i would say own threats knight g4 might
be a threat followed by rook takes f2
especially now that i put a bishop on d6
blocking queen takes d5 being a check so
just to put that in perspective if i
take on d4 you go
knight g4 now previously your bishop was
on b4 so queen takes d5 just as you were
saying
that would appear with check it doesn't
in this case and black has the free hand
to win his pawn back with rook takes f2
that's right i don't know if it's good
at the end because bishop takes h5 at
the end but you get the ideas that black
has some moves in this position exactly
it's a wild one it's very complicated
and it's the kind of chess that we want
to see timo has really been shying away
from complications for quite a while
yeah and today i'm glad to see him take
the bull by the horn and say this is
what richie's playing i'm not afraid of
the complications if i'm going to win a
game
let's go for a double-edged position and
that's what we've got and that's what i
really like speaking of winning a game
yes and i'm going to have to throw this
one uh to christian at some point as
well
when was the last time that timor rajab
won a classical game of chess
we just played in norway didn't win any
no he didn't win in uh
mania in gran chester a year ago yeah no
i think and i'm not 100 of this maybe
the chat can help us well var can
definitely help us at the event i think
the last time timor rajab won a game was
against dinleren in the 2019 world cup
that might be it yes
that that actually might be
wow that's quite a thought i mean you
got to go
back three years like what it's a lot i
mean normally you say something nice
like i haven't lost a game in three
years
uh you haven't won a game in three years
yeah he has played 35 classical games
without a win
that's not the kind of streak you're
supposed to be uh working on let's just
jump quickly to the game of uh ali raza
and
fabi because when we left it very early
it was with this
queen d3 a very very less
trodden path yes the move queen d3 has
been seen before it looks a little
artificial b7 b6 is immediately eye
candy bring my bishop to a6 fabi said
look i still want to play c5 this is a
catalan let me get in c5 and the nice
part of getting it in early is it's very
unlikely that white is going to play d4
takes c5 because knight a6 and knight
takes c5 is going to be very good for me
c5 castles take on d4 knight c6 and
rather quickly they got to these four
versus four
two versus two queens gambit accepted
type of positions which i think fabby
plays
just
just very very well and i'm just told
that the last move bishop to d7 is a
novelty what was the uh i could imagine
queen b6 just getting but what was the
stem game
what was the stem game
um
now you got me bamboozled
uh
by who
we're being told
i wanted to know
why who
don't ask too many difficult questions
uh
fabi uh alejandro uh queen g4 bishop d7
that looks like a very natural move to
my eyes
developing blocking the diagonal and
by the way exxon bishop i agree
excellent bishop i agree
i don't see that many problems here for
for for black i don't see anything
there's no problem there's no problem
there's no problems there's no problem
no no problems one player that is having
some problems right now and let's take a
look at what's happening here because
hikaru is styling in this game check
this out queen to e7 was played and just
before we left for uh the break he
immediately played the move knight to b5
creating an immediate threat and that is
to take on c7 you have to defend against
that queen to h4 forget about it
nobody's going to play that trying to
what sacrifice here take on e5 i i don't
understand queen to h4 but bishop takes
b5 came on the board and let me just
show you i was going through some
variations let me just show you this
beautiful line that could have um arose
on the board queen to b4
defending the pawn on a5 and attacking
the pawn on b5 at the same time e6
very natural move right opening up the
bishop sacrificing this one but he will
be taking on c7 and that's going to
create a pass pawn pass pawn on the b5
rook takes e6
bishop takes c7 rook to e8
and now i was trying to make uh the
position work for white how do i gather
well if i manage to exchange the queens
then this position most likely is going
to be an easy win for white because i'm
just going to start pushing my pawn
you're going to have to use your knight
as a resource to stop me from doing so
by putting it on the c file let's not
forget you also have a few weaknesses
especially this pawn on a5 that i'm
going to capture so
quinto a4 came to my mind quite quickly
okay check this out
knight to g3
check this move out which finishes the
game because now it's just a draw
rook takes e6
queen to e1 one check queen to e1 check
rook takes c1 and it seems like this
might have been the only way out for
dingley wren king to h2 and now knight
to f1 and we get a perpetual way
out from way afar
he should have anticipated that if he
was to go for this line because it's
very dangerous to give up the c7 pawn
and allow this uh b pawn to be ready to
be pushed down the board so big moment
that was for him he did not go for uh
queen to b4 in fact he went for knight
to g5 and finally
hikaru is thinking finally hikaru is
thinking and i see
the computer jumped a little bit just a
little bit 0.2 right now it's not zero
zero zero anymore
so now hikaru is in the driver's seat
but he does indeed
need to make very precise moves with all
that
hour too
extra hour i like the hour but when did
we start calling point to the driver
right so now he's happy you know chris
little john at home is looking at the
position i say hey karu i got you to
this point now you have a decisive
advantage right 0.2 go and win it bring
the bacon home yeah that that's very
very knight to g5 it seems like rook g3
is one option i was also looking at
bishop takes g5 i think this is a very
compelling idea as well try to eliminate
one of your best piece and then still
the ideas remain the same i just want to
push my pawns and try to take advantage
of the fact that i have a lot more space
on the king side the new queen takes g5
followed by rook two g3 it all comes
down to how fast can i push my f pawn if
i manage to go f4 f5 you're going to
have to react to that right you're going
to have to go f6 and if you go f6 e6
comes on the board and that's going to
secure an advantage for white it's still
despite the fact that there's only three
uh major pieces on the board for each
side remains a very complex game i i
couldn't agree more uh i'm thinking
though queen david four instead of rook
g3 that's an option uh the the pawn on
a5 is a kind of a weakness that is that
is definitely another kind of poster
you want to go f4 as i want to change
the queens now i thought the queen was
too strong on d4 as well yeah and that's
exactly what uh black needs to do get
rid of that queen as soon as possible
don't let white stabilize because with
the queen on g5 if i managed to get the
rook to c3 and stuff right right right
that's everything that's that's the
dream right that is right yeah um but
right now it all comes down to this f4
square try to stabilize the pawn
structure and then i will be able to
maneuver my rooks between c and d files
put pressure on the c and d pawns try to
take advantage of your weaknesses like
that it's still white who is to be
preferred and to be honest the white is
not risking much at this point so bishop
takes g5 definitely something that
hikaru needs to be considering right now
wonderful wonderful that's just such a
strange position also
it wouldn't come to me as the most
natural move bishop takes chief no
i i understand that uh it's not the side
of the board that we're looking at right
but why can't we take the pawn yes
the training
you
you don't know how long i've been
working with alejandro i mean years and
years and years but
finally it's finally paying off for both
of us look at this uh
let's look at that position i'm gonna
try to bring hikaru up on my screen as
soon as i can find it the first third
one third one there it is uh
yes you're sitting here this rook came
to a3 of course just as christian said
and we've been talking christensen
christian has been talking about you can
swing the rook across uh bishop takes g5
and rook g3 but the rook just happens to
be ideally positioned where the move
rook takes
uh
a5 i'm assuming you dropped the knight
back to e6
and you say okay i'm a pawn up but i do
get it that you've got your pass or two
and it's
well
it's it's a fight it's a it's a
three-year-old game right yeah it's a
and a very big uh fight indeed we
already talked about richard's fight
with the king on d7 but i just wanted to
finish he took on d4 which actually is
very interesting it emphasizes the point
that the rooks of white can't get in the
game how nice would it be to play rook
d1 here nice i mean it's like every
fiber in your being you're like why
can't i play rook to dv1 until you go
what is my opponent doing oh i see what
my opponent's doing my opponent is going
to drop a knight on g4
by the way you haven't castled your king
is on f1 rook is on h1 don't get any
hallucinations i mean as bad as black's
king is on uh the d7 square it's not
like f1 square is uh
is being teed up in any
good way for white uh
again i this is a mess it's a mess but
what is white's move here um
should i be playing something
weird
like i was gonna go queen e2 i don't
know we need to
i don't know what is my move quinine
i can't even start being greedy right i
could take an exchange with knight h2
you could
you could be greedy and take an exchange
with night age too
and you have really
conditioned that to throw in check mate
yeah that is an important tempo very
much so i
no i'm i'm dissatisfied
i'm not happy i'm very dissatisfied if
no i'm not happy here
at all just a second so queen takes d4
do i have to
you might have to trade the queens right
queen c3
you can go check you have queenie
one and
at least blunts some of the threats yeah
for for a moment uh
yeah i mean again the fact like you say
if i could just teleport a rook to d1
right here right right
that would be great
um by the way uh again we're having a
lot of fun with the odds i don't know if
you're enjoying it quite so much as
we are in terms of jockeying for
position and winning percentages so
coming into the event
dinglin wren was our tournament favorite
but nepo is our front runner at the
moment and let's just take a look how
the odds have changed as we proceed from
one round to the next the magic that's
graphics
when
when you have time what the graphic
artists
on studio can come up with
that's what they do the starting
position was based on their rating
because of course by that point uh you
will eventually have more white equal
amounts of whites and blacks exactly so
almost a third
so ding comes into the event with almost
a 30 chance of winning it
the highest percentage uh
as you see there
maybe around a 10 mark for nepo but in
the meanwhile nepo and especially you
see that graphic just surging to a 45
chance that nepo is going to be our
challenge yeah that win against alderaan
round three really
really catapulted him up there along
with the dingler in victory you beat
number one number two
they crisscross immediately
that's what happens love the graphic
toughness tournament for dailyrun
nepo just in the dream situation oh gosh
yes speaking of nepal's dream situation
how is his position at the moment we're
going to leave timor against
i think suffer a little bit against
rock borders we don't like his position
too much no we don't and
uh this is the game of nepali against
duda
king h2 i mean it's all good right
castles g4
f4
now uh what is it it's
i do love some of these uh opening names
i didn't know about the paul cares the
noah's ark
that's with
the you you trapped the bishop oh the
spanish yeah the spanish uh trap yes
yeah with an early d4 takes take c5 c4
yeah yeah yeah the noah's ark well here
we are we're we're about to play uh the
move f4 f5 trapping the bishop
no
says tuda i don't want to see my bishop
trapped and much like yourself there was
a moment ago that if something had come
into e4 it's very likely
that
this pawn on e4 would have simply been a
liability and i can imagine
white really wanting to embrace this
position
duda wanted nothing to do with that he
played the move h7 h6 he is encouraging
uh we saw
um it was against farouja where
um nepal played f4 f5 f6 yes against
yeah
the knight or through the pawn forward
and shall we have a look h7h6 what is
the difference right why did you play f4
okay now can i play f6
and take him with check yeah i play
bishop f4 how do you defend your bishop
i
how do i defend the bishop i was worried
about defending my king dude
i wasn't looking at defending my bishop
that's a very nice idea maybe you have
queen d4 maybe i missed this move so the
queen and bishop i have been
and
i thought queen takes f6 you were about
to take my bishop i was about to cry and
then you said well wait i can play queen
d4 yeah it's a tactical new nuance but i
think it works for black right it takes
you could move the rook
i might uh yeah i think i might move the
rook i don't know
complicated this suddenly got
complicated okay
can you prep that
uh f5 f6 to my eyes if you could get
that move in for free
yeah without any kind of uh
shall we try it i mean let's be greedy
and play for f6 right you're taking
advantage of this this perhaps allows
d4 d4 i think i can take it though right
that's it's
i don't really see the follow-up
here if rook to d8 you take on c5 no no
no no no no i was just gonna play e3
but then he mentioned rook c5 was pretty
good too
that's the free mission
the jedi mind tricks yes
i was going to play e3 but rook takes c5
yes christian how does it continue oh
that that's over
uh
but um
so let's take a look at that variation
because it's really important so you go
bishop to c3 right oh okay yes and now
the only way i can attack that pawn on
e5 is to reroute the bishop from c5
which doesn't really
do much on c7 so let's try that
uh truth be told i i just wanted to play
f6 because i i understand
this looks very nasty i'm not sure what
i'm doing is great i could play rook
takes f6 i could play rook ticks f6 i
get it guys really but i'm thinking if
my queen lands on h6 like just teleport
the queen so what if i go
d4 now
uh
i feel like you're about to be
immortalized let's let's see let's see
like fish here and venko or something
like that huh you can go yeah i think
that's okay e f oh boy let's have some
fun that that's a move that's a legal
movie queen e5
check i guess i gotta drop
back let's see
what hold on he's gonna go bishop c7
yes
keep going guys let me do the dance too
let me do the dance
how does the dance go
i like everything that you are saying
yes sir bishop c3 bishop c7 let me just
do it the conventional way and recapture
with the rook i think we got a little
fancy there for
probably no reason yeah the only issue
is that after bishop c7 it's not the
pawn that i'm worried about but again i
really like this move d4 yeah so i want
no no no not here i want to play the
move d4 david
now that bishop on c5 i always get
rooked to d8 and i don't see a good way
for you to defend that bishop i wanted
to play e3 that's okay and i have time
for um c5 now yeah now uh
unless i could get over there on the
king side like right away i have a
surprising lack of threats on the king
side remarkable right yeah okay so uh
fortunately for duda fans it's not all
play on one goal not yet at least and uh
he
does
does it make any
sense to somehow include the move e4
somehow i feel that
i i'm rushing into this that's quite
fair what is your feeling
yeah i mean you want to play moves like
f5 and f6
when you've done it at a time that
you're prepared you know you put your
queen on g3 like a lot of people
do and then you go e
f5 and g5 and it's sort of like yeah
well you've prepped your advance and so
you're ready to exploit it
sometimes you foolishly rush forwards
and it works as well
okay the direct way is the best way
that's it that's it
um so there we have it uh
still we like what nepo has
um
this is the first thing that hikaru's
had and it's a long think actually
hikaru how long has been spending here
17 almost 18 minutes he blitzed how many
moves
26
there's a lot of options guys i mean
bishop g5 was one option rook takes a5
is another option just take the pawn
right g3 is another option there's
plenty plenty of things to think about
right now so that's why he's taking his
long thing
i can't
maybe it was with my match with henrique
mecking
i'm trying to think of my absolutely
singular longest and best prep
when we said 26 moves for
hikaru
that's got to beat my record already by
some margin now i know like gelfand had
a novelty on move 37
in one long variation of the special
yeah yeah
mine your best prep
that went i mean in terms of depth like
but it's 28 30 moves it's kind of unfair
because i played this game against pablo
zarnicki in
argentina and gremlins a long time ago
yes but i got in i think
22 moves of prep nice and then he
resigned
so i didn't get to play the rest
oh
it was pretty bad
okay that was a good one but that's only
22 i mean
this is 20 26 yeah i don't think i've
gotten this far it's it's a lot of move
that's a lot of moves and it's not
usually my my style of play
to be all the way
uh not not usually like a machine all
the way to the end yeah everybody has
different styles even if you see the
openings of
the candidates here everybody brings
their own flavor to the tournament and
once you play magnus carlsen of course
you have to be ready to print out your
your uh your preparation your knowledge
your homework yeah yeah but
you don't have to do it so much in open
tournaments or
some other events where let's face it
you're not you don't really know what
you're going to be up against well
precisely but when you're playing in u.s
championships your your your prep had to
be
yeah pretty much world class i mean come
on yeah the us championships that i did
play uh i got some prep in i got a
couple novels to see in there but
nothing like this for 20 30. christian
your best uh preparation
how deep were you able to go uh i cannot
tell you the exact number but i do
remember this game i had against sam
savion with the white pieces in i think
it was philadelphia open or philadelphia
international one of those two
and i got around 20 moves of prepping
and i actually got a much better end
game which i converted so that felt like
a very successful uh preparation and i
think it was quite deep as well also
allowed me to gain a very significant uh
advantage on the clock i think around
40 to 50 minutes oh i i i think
alejandra i actually looked it up uh i i
was wondering how
deep it went i did play against nikolaj
braddock nikolaj
nikolaj yeah yeah uh in chorus and what
was called chorus back then yes what is
now known as tata steel right uh in the
bank of gambit and i got 21 right 21
moves in
21 moves of the benko gambit yeah nice
yeah it was a good prep
shortly after
says that's a part on a5 17 minute thing
18 yeah 18 minute thing rook takes a5
uh
christian uh he had bishop g5 he had
rook g3
and you also did mention rook a5 uh we
kind of just said rook a5 yeah yeah
that's a good move but knight e6 i don't
know exactly compensation from from a
practical perspective i don't know
whether i would commit to this move rook
to a5 and allow the knight to survive
stay on the board because right now the
knight on e6 is a tremendous piece
locating knight as well as defending
nicely the king side that pawn on g7
very very important as well as
supporting my own uh invasion via the
d-file right because i'm going to go d4
next so knight to e6 you have to drop
the bishop somewhere and i'm going to
get my counter play right b4 let's go d4
followed by d3 then maybe the knight
will jump to d4
that all of this only for a lonely pawn
on a five i'm 100 sure if that's a good
trade-off i would have preferred
sacrilege the idea or training is needed
take
take the knight i know there's more
training despite the fact that i'm the
treasurer
the upon grabbers association right it
just doesn't feel like uh it's a great
pawn i just don't see it by the way
knight to e6 bishop d2 is on the board
so they are blitzing out
their moves but after d4 it just feels
like black finally breeds a site of
relief finally i get something to play
for the initiative versus the uh
the the material it's such a difficult
thing to do right this cashing in of the
pawn and evaluating how many chances
your opponent gets after it i i know
that we've all failed it at some point
we've all looked at a game where we
thought
why did i take that stupid pawn i gave
the guy everything everything he wanted
yeah speaking of us champions i remember
i did that against honest trick i had a
beautiful prep got those awesome
position
then i took a quality five and it like
opened up everything for him and i was
like sitting in the middle of the game
like why why did i even consider taking
this spawn
off anderson once did that where he
and that he was forever cursing himself
why did i take this miserable
miserable is where neither of all they
came to and d4 just as you said
christian came very quickly by
as he's looking for
well
compensation for the miserable pawn but
again is the pawn on a5 right okay you
are an extra pawn but your extra pawn is
doubled right on the b file so it's not
like you have any sort of creating a
past pawn of your own immediately that's
not going to happen anytime soon you
still need to get rid of the c7 pawn as
well okay if you want to do that let me
play the devil's advocate i don't like
the pawn the partner i don't like the
rook anymore on the e2 square it feels
like i'm just
as a target so let me make the
precautionary
i'll drop back with the rook for just a
moment you're welcome to advance that's
a little bit further my queen on d1 is
it has been dreaming to jump out and
allow me to go rook to d4
david knight to d4 wait wait a minute no
no wait wait just one second sorry just
don't don't hurry me i know how you
you're like
ready to get ready to pounce i know how
you like the product you made it when
you made it let's go rook to d4 rook to
david for sure knight before it was
bishop takes h6
yeah i know you guys were getting ready
to do the dance i know okay uh
but
yeah i look everything is cool uh the
rook is fine on d4 but you were
mentioning that if you wanted to do
something you were ready to put your
knight there and you're and perhaps
perhaps i should have waited a bit
you're looking to age 8. kind of in the
way of maybe that's a problem
but what is that what is the
active follow-up like let's say that
black plays this king
so should i be playing with for rook a7
should you be playing for f4 f5
where is white's play exactly it exists
right right which one do you want well
the pawns here
i'm not sure that my rook by the way on
a5 is amazing is amazing anymore
um
yeah sure kind of let's go on d7 now
queen david seven let's target your pawn
on b5 as well okay at some point i'm
dreaming uh maybe it's an overreach by
myself
but it's something you have to get rid
of that of that knight on e6 is really
it's still good it's
uh here though i can imagine knight c5
and i should have maybe stopped you
right knight c5 coming with knight e4
also the queen blockading
the light square exactly so maybe uh by
the way rook a3 was played returning the
pawn and then playing for f4 um
very very intriguing game we did not see
the move queen g4 instead after d4
with the rook still on e2
he
i like this move i'm not uh unhappy
this this this move
makes sense uh eyeballing the d3
square so that when the pawn does get
there they will it'll be under attack
and the move i guess after rook d5 is to
go rogue g3 or
are we roo are we shifting back to a
king's head attack
okay
i mean at some moment you take this pawn
and i might play b4 and i'm just kind of
like okay i want to play f4 f5
everything i did on the queen side was
just a diversionary tactic it's always
been about playing f5 and bishop takes
h6
and having a party on at the king side
um the ikaru still for choice against
the number one seed
let's turn to
oh uh we've got to thank you for joining
the conversation alejandro uh well we
have social media questions coming up
let me take a look and
um
here we go here we go sir bryce anderson
if you are furuja or ding
how do you come back from a bad start to
a tournament wow
a very very good question and once again
one of those if i only knew the answer i
would put it in the package and i'd be a
multi-billionaire you know because
everybody has bad tournaments how do you
stop having a bad tournament how do you
recover from a bad tournament alejandro
i think it's such an individual problem
because losses affect people so
differently
some people just fall apart and some
people say no problem i'm going to play
a move
a game the next game no problems yeah i
think nepo is one of those places right
where he loses a game and you are really
worried he starts to spiral right we
don't have that much
information on ali reza first of all
he's a surging talent he hasn't lost
that many games that are important
recently right and
uh for ding i think that he's already
been here
he's so expensive he's like the most
mature
along with fabi yes fabi's been in that
anvil he knows what it it's like to
to win a number of games in a row and
well to have a bad result and stop and
stop right right so
i think that dingle iron is just gonna
he's gonna shake it off he's gonna do it
game by game and i think a lot of people
do this they just say whatever game by
game we have to take it day by day
there's no other way to play the
tournament
don't feel the pressure and i think
that's the most important thing don't
let the pressure get to you that you
need a point specifically after losses
at whatever level it always feels that a
player comes back to the tournament
thinking that they must win to get back
into
and sometimes it's just not the right
approach exactly a christian coach
christian
how would you answer uh the question
well at the same time
this is a very specific tournament the
candidates because in any other
tournament you're going to lose one and
then you're probably not going to be as
upset if you along the way finish on
plus one
plus two that's pretty decent right
right in any other tournament but this
one is winner takes all the type of
event in which if you don't win it you
feel like you just lost like a year of
preparation and another cycle in your
career and they don't come as often
right you look at fabiano he's on his
fourth cycle when uh he has the option
of potentially uh challenging uh magnus
carlsen but you look at the guy like
levon aronian for example he's already
36 37 38. he's pushing it and how many
cycles does ding have right now he's 29
years of age will he qualify for the
next one i don't know because there's no
more rating uh spot right right so you
have to be thinking about how many
chances are you going to get moving
forward in your career and we know that
this is the pinnacle of chess right
you're not going to get as many chances
so that pressure that you generally
don't feel in any other event you're
going to be feeling it in the candidates
now
speaking of these two players
specifically ali reza and ding there's
one common denominator and that is the
fact that they haven't played
much recently so they should have
expected that the start will be a bit
slower
alireza hasn't played in five years
before he came back in a bucharest and
he followed up with norway nevertheless
those weren't as many games as he
probably should have a guy at his age
right that was his strategy he chose it
he is coming with great preparation
right now but he's just not piling up
the points he doesn't there's some
rustiness with him and i feel that with
ding as well um it's very difficult
thinking in the back of your mind that
you still have to win
four games potentially to win this event
or tie
for the lead so the pressure is piling
up it's very difficult take it one game
at a time but at some point you have to
risk it all because this is a winner
takes all tournament if you don't risk
it uh you're just going to fade into
oblivion at some point you're just going
to be out of the tournament by making
draws that's basically what's happening
right now that's exactly exactly it
that's the fear
and again um
these
this event these games have been
incredibly incredibly hard fought
and winning
has become
almost an impossibility 11.
again i just want to remind everybody
we've had back-to-back
four draws for all the rounds 11
draws of the last 12 games it's been so
hard to win a game so these players
who are languishing at the bottom
um
man they're sitting there thinking
how do i win a game
and will i ever win two or three and and
and get to challenge nepo and fabi i
will i will play uh the other side of
that definitely completely i really do
think that the tournament will open up
for many reasons ah we there i there was
a wonderful article
written i think on chess base uh
describing
first half
candidates from 2013 and second half
candidates and how things do open up and
the reasons for that i feel people start
feeling the pressure yeah you see the
bottom seats thinking
where am i going to get my points right
a winner takes all tournament on a minus
one or minus two i gotta risk it i gotta
risk it for the biscuit and those guys
at the top are saying wait a second
you're gonna risk it let me take that as
a chance right to risk at it as well and
start separating myself from the plus
one plus two scores that are that are
currently at the top and the in the
leaderboard yeah they the players start
to feel the pressure
of needing to win of needing to win
right we don't feel that right now we
feel that it's still a tight tournament
even though early days it's early days
young is only really half a point
ahead of favi only one point ahead of a
lot of people right so it's still early
you don't i don't think that fabi's
sitting there oh my god i have to win
one of my next three games he still has
a long tournament ahead of him whereas
when we start reaching rounds you know
10 11 12
you're gonna start seeing people
well let's let's jump into the game of
alireza for a moment because we kind of
left it here and said
wow
farouza
you know you're white today
and you've really
got to put some pressure on your
opponent we just saw this last move
queen e7 i presume that he played the
move knight d2 with the purpose of
dropping the knight to et4 and
you know at least menacing or
threatening maybe i will get the two
bishops and uh fabi's just laid down the
gauntlet and said hey you want the two
bishops go ahead and take it if you do i
will rob you of this bishop on g2 by
recapturing with the temple sorry please
why out of curiosity do we need to give
up the bishop
can can i just move it
i didn't think you wanted to actually i
really didn't think you wanted to but
you're right
you could move the bishop bishop e5 and
i presume i have to
also maybe sidestep the threat of f5 how
do you feel with this current
configuration of pieces that i
understand what elirez is doing
to a certain degree
but i also feel that black's
better developed right yeah i know his
rooks are connected already yeah sure
so it feels a little artificial
artificial in that at some point maybe
black starts thinking about more than
equality no question about you start
thinking f6 or even f5 and that's a
possible move right uh f5
i didn't know i mean
now you are saying we are making some
committal just committing decisions here
and but but they might be okay because
you're better developed or developed you
can get away with some things in just
because your pieces are more active and
normally i don't want to really
mess up my structure over there but
if i get the time to bring in the rooks
rook c8 rook c2 nothing to discuss a
lifetime score uh not too many games but
boy one-sided yeah pretty one-sided favi
did beat farrugia i can at least
remember their first encounter was in
natata steal
that one went into in favor of fabi and
i don't recall the other
win but zero two so far
oh the which grand swiss it wasn't this
grand swiss
the last grants oh that's right five
needed to win this one to catch uh
ferruja and eventually ferruccio won on
tiebreaks anyway
right oh and we have uh christian with
more about that blast from the past
nice
guys i mean he's keeping us
you know
he's keeping the good stuff for himself
right right right that's fine
but you're making a very good point that
uh just look at the development queen e7
on the last turn
you're right i might have been a little
bit more like okay i'm just black i'm
just just drunk you make make the draw
yeah secure my my my seating and
everything but you're saying yes sir
show a little ambition
and i think specifically the type of
player that uh fabi is he shows he shows
an ambition he is the type of player
that thinks well you've given me
something to play for at this point it's
my duty as a chess player to take up the
gauntlet and try to punish you and it's
a lot of it's a big time difference
because remember that ferruja came with
this idea of queen d3 surprises right
fabi in the opening fabi
thanks yes he does he does he's what's
up with this queen d3 move let me think
of what's going on he does play c5 yeah
but he ends up the opening if we call
the opening phase after knight takes d5
with the following time situation
ali reza on move uh when move 10 was
completed yeah had an hour and 45.
and
fabiano had an hour and 26.
and now all the way down a few moves
later
three months later pardon me this is
move 10 queen takes d4 at this moment
and i think after knight takes d5 yes
yeah and hour 10 for white an hour 45 an
hour 45 part b for white an hour 26 for
black okay and that's so white white's
nice yeah i got this i got this i got
this and then let's go a few moves
let's go to the current position oh to
the current position fair enough sorry
this is the current position current
position fabi uh alireza has 45 minutes
so he used an hour for three moves
something he did yesterday too uh
against um duda
uh i guess dude i'm sorry yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah with a furuga i meant
he he blitzed out all of this wonderful
uh anti-petrov stuff i've got this i got
this and he got nothing he got nothing
and he tanked right right
to get there so
an hour over three four moves
and he hasn't gotten any advantage again
hikaru nakamura however his
opening uh
preparation
has kind of staggered us
and
into silence we were just really really
impressed by what hikara has done queen
to c5 on the board
and how do we like these apples by the
way because this is actually queen c5
you do i do you do okay so let's just
take
i think this knight by the way on e6 is
such a marvelous kind of a monster
defender let me let me try from the
white side
my dream
i'm gonna
sidestep d3 with a move like rookie 4.
but for the moment rook g3 does have the
rather well should i say it uh barbaric
threat of uh
let me capture on h6 what if i go d3
though
all right
and let's go rookie four i could go rook
here as well yes you could now i want to
drag your pieces backwards go uh
i'll play them with queen c2
nobody's
uh what alexander ivanov a good russian
never retreats what are you how are you
dragging my pieces backwards
uh i don't know
um
i want to go
yeah i understand that
that's why i wanted to get you off this
diagonal yeah now you don't have queen
g4 now
it was funny if you had played king h8 i
was ready to go bishop h6 i'm sure you
were but i don't want to see any of that
and i actually don't know if you have a
threat uh bishop takes h6 does uh
allow d2 d2
so
i will suggest that i don't have a
threat yes so
i will
i'm planning rook on e4 to g4 so that i
will have a threat and then we'll have a
threat right
well as we struggle to understand how
big an advantage or not hikaru has
you got a feature first christian let us
have it absolutely well it's time for
blast from the past
guys and we've been discussing this big
battle between ali reza and fabiano and
we're trying to remember when did
fabiano beat alireza right well it was
actually in the grand swiss that very
important tournament that actually
qualified both players to the candidates
alireza won the event fabiano came close
behind in the second position and they
both qualified for the candace
tournament but it was at this point
round number eight a very important
round because fabiano was trailing
alireza by one full point he had the
white pieces and he had to win it
because if you don't win with the white
pieces and you're trailing by as much as
one point you're probably not going to
make it he came well prepared and let's
see what happened fabiano by the way so
reverse colors to what we have right now
fabiano had the white pieces in this
game e4 started off very aggressively
with this h4 response against the
karakan h5 bishop to d3 and we blissed
out to this variation knight to e7 and
then came the move b4 this was the big
uh novelty prepared by fabiano and his
team that threw off alireza for example
if you uh just simply go castle which is
the regular move in the position knight
to f5 develop the knight knight to f3
now black has this move queen to a6 and
it starts to be quite apparent that the
queen on d3 doesn't have a lot of
squares right well actually in fact only
one to not lose the knight on e2 if you
want to avoid the queen trade and you do
want to avoid the queen trade because
the end game is not imbalanced enough to
give white any prospects for an
advantage so queen to d1 has to be
played and after c5 it does feel like
black doesn't have too many problems now
after the move b4 in the game now c5 is
no longer possible and that's a huge
difference and let's see how the game
continued queen to b3 knight to f5
knight to f3 and we got to this end game
which is very different to what we've
seen uh as a potential after queen to a6
knight to a6 in the previous lines
because the pawn is on b4 and there is
no more counter play with the move c5
for a black and unfortunately for
fabiano knew what he's doing and at this
point he found this beautiful idea with
knight to d5 centralizing the knight you
cannot
take on d5 because e6 is going to come
and that's going to destroy your whole
position and went on to win
not necessarily a smooth game actually
alireza had his own chances but i
remember precisely when he had those
chances what he didn't have was time on
his clock and that was the big problem
and unfortunately for him we reached
move
38 this was the moment right now
rook to e8 was still within the margins
of equality he did not play this move he
only had i believe 38 seconds at this
point and he played the move knight to
d4 which allowed white to get a decisive
advantage after bishop takes b4 bishop
takes d2 and now i just simply keep my
pawns i have too many pawns close to
promotion you're not going to be able to
defend against all my threats despite
the fact that you have an extra night
fabiano went on to win this one they
both went on to qualify for the canada's
tournament but this one was such an
important game for both of their careers
no question about it is it propelled
farrugia into the candidates
and he stunned the chess world and got
the whole chess world excited
but in truth with what we saw in
bucharest and what we're seeing in this
tournament
maybe that ambitions of let let farouja
become world champion challenger or a
little bit premature
he hasn't
in his preparation today his preparation
yesterday kind of shows that it's not
100 it's not what you need to become a
world champion yeah not quite yet it
feels like it's still lacking certainly
it's still lacking some proper prep it's
still lacking details here and there you
can definitely see
uh that he's gonna be such a great
player for so many years exactly
is he worth you being the challenger
well that's what we're trying to figure
out because he's gonna really have to
turn this ship around right in order to
qualify and
um if he does it uh today against fabi
well then
you know that happened
because that that's a complete equality
before we jump on break i just want to
leave a thought with our tournament
leader uh we got to this position and we
got really excited i did at least i
wanted to go f5
and bravely rush in and play for the
quick f5 f6
no no no no said
john i've been on this rodeo before
first you bring your
you you reposition you bring your pieces
into the position so that when you do
play the move f6 your queen is ready to
exploit the fact that you're opening up
the the lines he played queenie one
rookie a queen g3 making f5 available
followed by f6
in my opinion opinion very good move by
duda
getting ready for the big blow f5 so he
simply sidesteps things
and guess what
nepo is not to be not not a man easily
uh stopped
you know f5 is not going to trap your
bishop well i'm going to go h
h5 and g5 and trap your bishop this is a
fun game and we're going to see you guys
on the other side of this break yeah
we'll have a small feature for you it's
park side chat it'll be i believe it's
me and maurice oh wow i remember those
[Music]
maurice what a pleasure chess in the
parks chess in the parks this is where i
grew up playing chess like for me this
is this is home playing in new york city
playing in brooklyn prospect park
uh even in manhattan washington square
park it was always a lot of fun oh for
me it's always been like that i've had
the pleasure of playing around the world
in different parks and you get to meet
this real hustlers you can see their
tactics their tricks it's been amazing
and
i think new york has the trickiest ones
man those guys in in new york city
they've mastered the art of the hustle
first of all there's always got to be
trash talking like there's no chess
without trash talking we play in the the
club we do commentary in the club and
everybody's quiet and all no
you better take your feelings and park
them somewhere because guys are going to
talk about your mama about your sister
about your best friends and about your
chess moves and you have to be on top of
stuff
i've seen players they're beat up titled
players that come in their confidence
trotting like they know what's going on
they say
park players amateurs i can beat them up
i've seen them you know go home being
just on the receiving end of some nasty
tricks well the legends of the park you
got guys like
vinnie livermore
ralph mouth
lightning sam all these guys they knew
how to get inside your head the point is
you think you're playing chess but
you're listening to them at the same
time and you know just the right thing
to say to throw you off and there's an
art to that there's an art to
distraction
that's what it's all about when you're
playing and then you had like the nasty
tricks sometimes in the old school
jurgers you know the analog clocks
somehow your side would move a little
faster like wait a minute how come my
time is down already or you got the
hustle where when it got down to the
blitz how suddenly all the moves they
made were close to the clock every move
every move was on the side of the clock
so that your flag would fall before
theirs did it was always some kind of
trickery to get your money out of your
pocket money out of your pocket but i
think you've gone around new york how
did it feel the experience of playing
against them man i was playing in the
park and i get my butt kicked getting my
money taken my lunch money taken by
these guys it was just the way you
learned it was just part of being a
chess player in the parks not only also
with the trash talking scene you had a
bunch of guys that's hanging out
sometimes ladies you'd have music
playing you'd be saying cyrus police
cars were going by i'm talking about
this was the hood fulton park as well
and we would just that would be normal
for us so to me that kind of cutthroat
atmosphere
where it was all about winning and you
might get your money taken really
prepared me for what would come when i
was in clubs and you know nobody be
quiet
everything was just high-end yeah for me
it was the same way i grew up a blitz
player i went to in costa rica and i
just played gangsters you know they
would like hustle for absolutely no
money but that was all they had
and i had to learn how to be tricky i
was actually had to slow myself down
when i became a norm hunter because i
was just playing too quickly and too
tricky
but it's always been part of my culture
as well and i love going around the
world to different parks and just seeing
people play luxembourg park absolutely
paris absolutely gorgeous
around moscow you can see people playing
all over i had a great time in avana and
i was just going around the park and i
saw i wasn't even planning on going to
play chess and i was just seeing some
people you know
playing for fun i checked it out man
they were good man they were solid chess
players you can see the attacks you can
see the tricks they were playing some
theory i was like
not easy anymore part chess can't be
underestimated you know it's funny when
i was playing i remember what the the
park players they used to try to play in
tournaments right but even playing in
tournaments they tried to hustle it
right they keep their ratings down they
wouldn't they you know under section
they might you might one or two
sandbaggers might shoving all right show
that they can play in the under 2000
sections under 1800
and try to win money these guys were
2200 strength in blitz but you know it
was funny because they wouldn't be able
to sit still for hours on end they'd be
like yo make a move
because they're used to going like this
so they'd be sitting there and they'd
come out they would rarely win big money
at those tournaments it was a difference
between park chess and serious
over-the-board tournaments yeah and they
and they would tell me to try to keep my
braiding down i was like come on i'm
trying to become a grandmaster i'm not
going to keep my rating low but it was
always about the hustle and that would
keep them back they it would keep them
back but man they're tricky sometimes
you see them play against strong players
i would say even up to feed a master
international master level and you'd see
man the 1600 um you know that's not
right so that is absolutely not right
how do they know so many tricks and
sometimes the positional understanding
it's not there it's the flick of the
wrist i'm gonna trip you i'm gonna trick
you and
very dangerous people auto tactics
matter of fact there's a video of me
playing a hustler in washington square
park and he tried to take well i won't
spoil it for people who would watch it
just to say he did a move i'd never seen
tried
ever like ever in the history of my
playing chess it is after years and
years i mean decades of playing and i
played this thing i was like
this guy actually pulled this hustle
trying to cheat in the middle of a game
and i respected him for it i was like
that was funny like you actually
practiced that and tried to pull it off
he could have done it a lot better i
still would have seen it but it was a
great great move
i i think it's just a resourcefulness
when it comes down to it the practice of
being resourceful at so many different
things in chess and i love the
creativity they bring to it it's the
clock it's the tactic it's the it's the
doom i'm not
i love that one it could be on two four
squares at once four squares no my
bishop just changed color what are you
talking about in the middle that you're
like wait how did that bishop i thought
it was a white square bishop now it's a
dark square bishop stuff like that is
just priceless and you gotta land for
defend for yourself nobody's gonna be
like yeah of course that bishop no you
gotta fight for your rights in those
games there's no arbiter to call over
hey chris bird can i have some
adjournment no i don't
know
you're in the middle of the war and it's
fun like i said the trash talking
uh the the music
uh the joy of the game the fun of it and
the cutthroat aspect you'll see people
stand around the chessboard in a park
and watching
like they're watching magnus cross and
play hikaru nakamura because people are
showing off it's the when hikaru and
magnus and all these guys they play a
brilliant move you know they played and
they they might adjust their piece a
little bit more than another you're at a
point like boom baby i'm here to play
chess come watch i'm playing this
brilliancy it's just a different
atmosphere and the language uh will get
a little um
you know let's just say we can't talk
talk about that when we're at the st
louis chess club yeah but
the flamboyance and the language guys
would be quoting shakespeare
he was like who's this guy and they're
mixing in street with
old school classical
everything it's i i think i think it
would make a great show
if it was all about park chess it would
i think i made great tv maurice i'm
getting fired up let's let's play some
chats let's do this
this is i feel like i'm back back and
you can't even make moves man come on
you're trying to cheat me i'm nervous
nervous just making me nervous play
chess look at this guy you name it pack
it give me a break this is a boring this
is how you play chess oh my sister plays
better than this you don't even know how
to play chess do you want the best from
the fourth rack out of here that lady
ain't gone
backwards come on give me a break
forward oh this guy do you know how to
pass the fourth rank
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody we are a couple
hours already into round number six of
the candidates that means that we are
done with the opening and straight into
the fight they remember that yanni pogba
she's still sitting pretty at three and
a half out of five his plus two gives
him a half point advantage over fabiano
carrana the only player on three points
at the
moment wow uh i just got to say that i'm
still
buzzed about the game between timor and
richie uh truth be told i don't know
what's going on let's try to figure that
us to be out
wow when we left it we left the position
with the queens on the board and it was
about here where i was having trouble
first of all on the white side with uh
timor and
very reluctantly i had to come up with
the move queen c3 but he did agree with
you that the queen on d4 is too powerful
there are too many circumstances
well it's that knight g4 move in
particular with the rook bearing down on
the f2 pawn that i really despised which
is what provoked me to move my queen in
the first place and then after the queen
trade richie said well you've got issues
uh you can't really play the move b2b3
because bishop e5 was going to spear a
rook and as the game proceeded uh timor
said yeah yeah yeah well you took the
pawn but guess what i've got uh my own
ideas uh including knight c4
check
the king went and now came this move
exciting
now we do have f2 f3 on the board
already right so we understand that that
move has been played but what was it
that timor didn't like about knight
takes d2 and we think it was just the
take the material you take the pawn with
check and
white's king and white's rook on h1 are
crying yeah that's a little iffy it's
like on a good day you only end up down
two pounds when black ends up recovering
that exchange exactly but that's a good
day yeah
and
there could be some dark days ahead too
knight g4 f3 on the board
and for richie
this a win today in this chaotic uh
fight as black
would be absolutely humongous check king
g1 and i'm thinking he's going to play
the move bishop c5 setting up
a discovered the idea is that if you do
take but that's how it usually goes guys
you get these wild games and then they
fizzle out into some sort of a draw no
don't question this christian don't do
that you're gonna tell me i'm gonna have
zero first bubble guys i'm sorry i'm
sorry yeah keep going you're on the
right track oh no but that's just zero
zero zero zero you're kidding no
no knight to e3 knight to e3
e3 once again it forces matters knight
to e3 you have to take now i go king to
h2 you take on g4 most likely because
well not with the pawn sorry if you take
with the point i take on f4 and then go
g3 i think you might have some problems
there right oh probably yeah maybe the
end game is not so you take on g4 i take
on e3 you take on g6 you do have two
extra pawns but i feel like i have a lot
of compensation especially with rook to
d1 or b1 also coming this one is going
to fizzle out into some sort of control
also bishop to g5 you have to be careful
you do have two pawns but i have a lot
of compensation not only that but i i
think the material is too limited at
this point well i still i'm trying to
get the zen in the position and the next
thing you know i'm in a bishops of
opposition landing i i thought there's
some kind of mating attacks and crazy
things going on we do have bishop c5 on
the board
um i was wondering am i missing some i
mean
don't i have the feeling like
you're not doing the business but
there's no business to be had you're not
missing anything it's a very similar
game to what we've we've seen yesterday
between fabiano and richie this while
the ferry which just finishes at some
point in a forced uh variation uh yeah
that was a forced repetition against the
queen
it just feels like i mean black is
i mean this rook on h1 is pathetic man i
mean i got i got so many threats i
didn't even sacrifice i'm not a pawn you
didn't sacrifice anything you're up
there
taking your knife this is it
give me the knife
i guess
give me the knight well the thing is
if i manage to stabilize and get the
king out and then connect the rooks and
get them into play
then strategically it's actually and
from a dynamic point of view as well i'm
the one with the initiative right the
bishop c8 is not really playing you need
to open it up uh by playing the move e5
at one point
but that weakens the pawn structure as
well so your king in fact is quite weak
also impromptu the attacks if you don't
pay a lot of attention so you got to be
careful you got to make the first moves
and it seems like we are actually headed
straight into the variation that i was
just pointing out uh could i uh
take a different approach christian for
just a moment so we're going to take the
night
and after the rook discovered check
to the king
threatening to pick up the night instead
of your knight e3 suggestion which is
probably the best move don't get me
wrong
if i try to avoid those triple zeros the
dreaded triple zeros so now you're
trying to play for a win with white
exactly okay so let's take on c4 now uh
the desirable move is to play rook check
i want to take on h5 with the pawn i'm
afraid if i play rook check right away
you
counter me counter check you yeah with a
check and
i may be advised to give up an exchange
i'll have a three versus one majority
for the two bishops it's just him
actually that's pretty interesting right
i mean it is very interesting i take
that of course that's an that's a munch
i think i throw in the check i like the
check because
you're not going to see five uh you're
probably dropping back to c7 you could
go forward wait wait wait maybe i'll go
up if you go up maybe i'll go try i'll
adjust the draw right if you go king e5
rookie one maybe i can still play for
white by the way rook to f4 is uh on the
board you could play with taking on h5
right by how is that position yeah
yeah that's what i wanted
i don't feel that white is doing poorly
and this is what i'm talking about right
you are a couple i like it at the
beginning of this whole condition but
your bishop on c8 is kind of dead right
exactly that's what we're playing
against right right right yeah
oh wait a second why didn't we play
bishop e7 in the previous move i have no
idea bishop b7 bishop d6 g oh my bishop
on g6 is hanging all right
you you forced my
uh what can i say this is a crazy
position
these kinds of creative positions i
think are
richards
bread and butter not to suggest that
timor in any way uh doesn't like these
positions he's much
as a king's indian defense player he
likes the chaos too he loves laughter he
loves
there was a period of time where he
thrived in the chaos right
so
you know who who's in their element best
hard to say
christian breaking news yes sir we were
saying that this position starting from
a very long time ago
it's all about white having fun yeah
white enjoying the position pushing his
pawns trying to kick black uh away and
it does seem like this is exactly what's
happening it's all about this avalanche
of pawns that's coming your way and you
have to find a way to stop me from doing
it and it doesn't seem like duda was
able to do so because check this out the
last few moves we laughed it off after
the move h4 this was before we went on a
break h4 rook 88 g5 sure let's hook the
pawn you have upon on h6 i'm going to
hook it immediately h takes g5 already a
big mistake the only way to continue in
fact at this point was to go king to h8
the point being that if you go king to
h8 after you trade off the h pawns
the h file is going to be decisive
i'm going to be able to go rook to h1
followed by king queen to h4 king to g3
open it up and checkmate u you don't
want to see that on the board so
king28 was the only way to keep the
balance in the position because right
now after h5 then i will take on g5 and
now you're going to have some problems
with your pawn on e5 and i do have
another square on g8 whenever you uh
threaten trap that bishop so king to h8
important move he did not play it
he fell under pressure right now and
took on g5 but this allows hg5 the
opening of the h5 and now
the defense becomes more and more
difficult and he played the move a
bishop to b for currently this is the
position we have on the board but the
simple question is
what if i just stay
take and then continue pushing chest
sometimes it's easy sometimes you have
to make the easy moves right
it can be an easy game
yeah g6 is coming so you have to defend
against that how do you defend do you
play g6 yourself i don't think so
i don't think so
no no no no
i feel a million voices crying
this is the dream this is the dream for
white of course but
what else you're going to go queen to e7
sure g6 is one way
i'm not necessarily seeing the
compensation after that no no i don't
see it guys
how do you defend king to f8 is that it
but g6 you're gonna get check made it
here
yeah f5
this is over but
i think we do have
we have a very special guest christian
thank you yes we have former
uh u.s champion sam shanklin and uh
nice to see you my friend how are you
good how are you guys doing great what
do you think of the candidates
uh it's definitely been an interesting
tournament so far in a lot of ways it's
not wildly surprising i mean one thing i
said after the match um
with uh nepalese carlson is i believe
nepo a like nepo on forum is probably by
some margin the second best player in
the world it's just often he really
struggles at the end of tournaments he
deals with losses badly he can tilt and
nepo b is just not that strong he's
really showing nepo a so far and i think
he's clearly played the best chess but
the real question can be can he buck the
trend uh that he's shown in the past
going into later rounds if he can i
think he's going to run away with his
tournaments but if not i think the
tournament's wide open there's a lot
there's been a lot of other interesting
stuff i think the guy who's probably
brought the best preparation has been
ding uh and he's gotten a lot of good
positions but he's messed them up so
he's clearly off form a bit um
one thing i said before the tournament
was
i believe that there were no two players
whose combined chances of winning the
tournament exceeded 50 percent that is
if someone wants to make a bet with me i
would let you choose any two players you
want if i get the other six i think i'm
a favorite i'm not necessarily sure i
would still believe so today especially
if napomnishi wins i think he's a pretty
serious favorite at that point
but i still think the tournament's very
open
wow definitely something that we thought
coming in thank you for joining us
we're not letting you go sam we just
thought that was a great
explanation uh nepo a and napo b that
was perfectly expressed
i like that a lot and i agree with sam
completely that he has shown incredible
willpower in this tournament i really
like the way that he played against
alireza it seemed that he was the one
surprised and he still came back played
his chess and just destroyed his
opponent
yeah for sure it was that was a
fantastic game i thought farrugia made a
very poor opening choice in in terms of
practicality um
i think this line is objectively fine
for black i just think the positions are
much harder to handle from the black
side in fact i actually had
this line exactly with duda in prague
last year and you won that a very
beautiful game by the way yeah i just
completely killed him like very easily
and then the rest of the tournament he
made like five out of six and then he
went off and won the world cup so you
know it just
you know it felt like uh you know the
opening did not do him any favors there
um but yeah i mean it's it's just can
napo keep himself together i mean i've
only played nepal twice in classical
chess but i've played nepo a once in
nepa b once and nepo a played an
absolutely brilliant game against me
like all the way through to the end
wildly complex and i like to think i
calculate pretty well but he just did it
better and he like
just played this beautiful game and
eventually
in some like rook and bishop versus rook
and pawns end game and then um
and then when i played nepo b um
he played
d6 g6 e6 a6 b6 and lost in 10 moves so
are you sure that wasn't that c
yeah i don't know it's just it it really
feels like the guy is capable of
absolutely fantastic chess but he's also
capable of really mediocre chess and so
far he's shown the former and we'll just
see if that continues through the
tournament well help us out a little bit
sam we do have some of the games going
on right now and we think he's a great
position
first of all sam i do want to ask you a
bit about the two american players
hikaru came into the event as a dark
horse and actually a wild card in uh to
the grand prix and then qualifying to
the candidates how do you see his
chances as well as fabiano's chances um
so again i don't think the chances of
any one particular player are wildly
high like before the tournament started
i would have said ding had the best
chances of anyone at i don't know 25 or
20 so even like the guy who i would say
was most likely to win before the
tournament started like i still think
much more likely than not will not win
the tournament just because it's
reasonably compact i think the two of
them have both shown uh quite reasonable
chess so far i'm a little concerned for
hikaru's position at this point
uh
and
it's
um why did you see ding as the favorite
because he hasn't played outside of
china in a year and a half he only
recently crossed back the 2800 barrier
and come came into the event as a rating
favorite why did you see him as the
favorite um part of it is maybe i'm just
a little bit uh
too methodical and mathematical ratings
do not lie i mean they're a strict
function of wins and losses that you've
accomplished against players i mean i in
general i do believe in the rating
system um in terms of intangibles uh
i've played all of these guys a bunch
for what it's worth and just ding has
absolutely clobbered me and everybody
else i have a totally fine score against
so just in my own personal experience
he's the one who scares me more and he's
the highest rated so like i considered
him
a favorite as a result but still like
you know if you said will ding win the
candidates certainly more likely than
not the answer is no but i just thought
he had a better chance than like any
other one individual player
good sam if i can get your
input on some of the games let's start
with yan
as you say we've got
nepo a
and
as you were coming on air we saw a trade
of bishops f5 we really like what nepo's
been doing queen takes b2
take us through your thought process on
this position how you would evaluate it
if nepo wins my god is he securing a
huge lead
um i don't think there's much if i'd say
the odds of nepa winning this game are
well over 90 it just looks totally
crushing to me
give us what you think would be the most
i mean e6 certainly feels the most
thematic um i think duda is basically
begging for g6 and just hoping to like
sacrifice a piece and somehow try to
fight on with some pawns in a reasonably
solid position
here my suspicion is white is much
better too but i think like you know
i mean basically if you told me if i put
g6 on the board will you beat magnus
with white here my answer is possibly
not but e6 just looks totally over to me
um
and i think he will play it and here
it just
i don't know it just feels like
everything should crash through g6 is
fine maybe you can flick in rook b1 uh
to try to invade the seventh rank
there's just it just feels like it's
totally falling apart for black yeah i
don't know especially after this cool
move rook me i like this
one too i mean the moment you said it
and indicated uh the rook crashing
through
uh okay so that's nepo
a uh
the the a lot of twists and turns going
on in this uh huge match-up ali raza as
the number two seed struggling but
maybe
an opportunity against fabi this is an
incredibly important game
uh there's a strange-looking catalan how
would you evaluate the current position
so this one i actually would struggle to
give you like a gut instinct just
because i actually it's funny because it
looks like it's symmetrical but actually
this is much more dynamic than
it appears at first glance
um i think thematically black should be
better here just because he is closer to
getting to the c file his knight on b4
is much better than white's knight on f3
the queen on h5 could definitely end up
misplaced but it's also very concrete in
that you can clearly see like moves like
knight g5 or bishop g5 or even like in
some cases i mean not now but at some
point rook d7 bishop h3 there's all
sorts of things that could happen to
black here so
i think if black can keep this position
under control he should be better uh but
that's a big if and i'm not sure if
white has like something direct here um
i don't know this one it's certainly
harder for me to know
directly who's who's better um i would
probably want to think for a bit more it
seems pretty dynamic actually what would
be your first instinct you said that
white needs to try some dynamic ideas
and i completely agree that black seems
like it's he's taking over what would be
your first instinct and what to look at
here for white
um
i don't know uh
well it would depend i mean if i want to
make a draw probably if i decide i'm
worse than i want to make a drop
probably i would look at bishop h3 i
think it's a bad bishop and we can trade
it off for a good one
if i want to be more ambitious um bishop
g5 would probably be the first thing i'd
think of um g4 is probably a little bit
too outlandish but it's not totally
ridiculous
um g4 i like it no but there's g6 and
then queen h5 yeah yeah and if queen h6
you have bishop g7 so or even just
bishop g4 and you're not going to get
mated after knight g5 so yeah i would
think with white i mean it really feels
like bishop g5 should probably be the
move but
i don't really love the position
honestly
i don't think but the the nice thing for
white though is i don't think it can be
that terrible i think or worse it's
going to be a slightly worse and you
know ferruga is a good player that being
said firuja is now down to 18 minutes
for a full 24 moose of chess remember no
increment
yeah sure um you mentioned you felt like
a karu's position
you thought that dink coming into the
tournament ding was the favorite
hakaru's position in the moment hikaru
is a pawn up we just saw the move queen
c5 and there have been
different long things this looks uh to
us like one of hikaru's long things try
to break down this position for us
um if he could sam well again
thematically it feels like black should
be better i mean if he's able to play
queen takes b5 and c5 and c4 like his
moves are very straightforward and he
basically just crashes through and wins
the game so
um
i think in this line the big point is
you're trying to go give mate with white
but somehow the way black has
coordinated his pieces like if you go
rook g3 and just start swinging for the
fences i don't think you're gonna mate
after king f8
um
i don't know if king f8 is the best move
but like it feels like there's not
enough pieces on the board and you're
always looking for like sacrifices
bishop h6 quinn d2 but i think we're
like there's enough pieces of being
exchanged that light not only does white
lack the firepower needed to actually
crash through and give mate but also
because black's pieces have been
exchanged his king has a pretty clear
route to e7 and d7 and c8 to escape if
white ever starts sacrificing too much
stuff that's awesome um
which is not necessarily always the case
if you know black has like a bishop on
e7 or something it often can actually
make the defense harder so
um
yeah i don't know i mean i don't think a
car is in objective trouble yet but the
position does look uncomfortable to me
and i don't like that he had a huge time
advantage and that's clearly gone now
and he's actually less time
burning this much time this fast means
you're somewhat uncomfortable with your
position i think
before we ask you what's on your agenda
and
so on i want to get your quick take on
the time control
nobody plays this time control not much
experience we're all used to the
increments
and now you only get the increment after
move 60 your perspective on the time
control used is a little embarrassing
but the first thing i'll ask is what is
the time control 40 moves in two hours
and then you get another hour until you
can reach move 60 on move 60 you get 15
minutes now when you delay no
well you do get increment once you reach
move six until you meet
and then your 30 seconds start ticking
um
[Music]
i don't know i i don't care that much
honestly i think it's it's probably the
difference is pretty marginal i mean
there's guys out there who just love to
burn all their time down to nothing and
will burn all their time regardless of
whether they start with two hours or
whether they start with 90 minutes so
for them
i think they might struggle a bit for me
i don't see a a really substantial
difference um
i think
this time control or a more normal time
control i still think it's very likely
that whoever plays the best chess is
just going to win the tournament and i
don't think the time control will have a
huge amount to do with it okay and
what's happening in sam shanklin world
well i just got home from prague
and now i'm actually uh stuck at home i
tested positive for covert a couple days
ago but um
finally i'm actually like feeling
totally fine i've been doing push-ups
and pull-ups and chin-ups and you know
doing my normal training and teaching
classes i'd say i feel like 90-95 fine
but you know still i should i slid until
i'm negative but uh so how do you know
you have covet well i test the positive
oh
as well
you know there you go
nobody's getting tested anymore you
didn't have to get tested to travel did
you no but i just like so i felt really
lousy on tuesday and i took a test and
it was positive but like within a day i
was basically feeling like 95 healthy so
you know i'm still gonna test and stay
at home until i'm negative but like it's
it's uh i feel totally fine um
and uh
but yeah after that i have i guess next
up for me would be i have this magnus
tour uh the online events and then i
have the olympiads and then after that i
have no idea i mean there's events i'm
hopeful for but i just don't know about
uh and uh we'll see it's sort of a tough
spot in that you know you're not really
i i haven't been invited to stuff yet
and there's
when you're at like the level i'm at you
know which is you know say number 20 to
30 in the world there's all these
tournaments that you're clearly good
enough to play in and that there's a
chance that you could get invited to but
you're definitely not guaranteed to be
invited to right uh and that you know if
you were number 50 in the world you're
like yeah i'm not getting invited and if
you're number 10 in the world you're
like yeah i'm playing and here you know
there's a very real chance that you'll
play and you know that you could be
competitive and you know it could come
but you're also
not guaranteed it makes it a little
harder to plan your schedule but uh i'm
basically open and um
and i'm hopeful that you know i could
for example play like uh if there's any
grand chess tour events that you know i
got a wild card too last year i was
obviously delighted to play and i would
love to do that again of course i
understand there's a lot of players who
also would love to play but yeah we'll
we'll just see um but next up is
olympiad where i'll be playing for usa
well first of all play great at the
olympia second of all we'll be seeing
you at the u.s championship in october
yes that is definitely true it starts
right after my birthday
no i'm glad to see you in india of
course always good to see sam shackleton
represent america it will be a great
team that we're sending over there to
the olympia and thank you very much sam
for taking time out of your covet
[Laughter]
to join us it was our pleasure yeah it
was so great to see you guys and enjoy
the rest of the broadcast thank you very
much sam recover quickly yes
a nice idea by uh
just kind of get out of there king fa
king e7 kingdoms
you've sacrificed your pieces but none
of that will happen before we get into
that yes oh yes i just want to show you
a wild variation please that just could
have happened but it didn't oh it's the
game between yana pomoniasi and shishtav
duda and obviously e6 is the most
natural option right e6 followed by g6
this is what happened in the game and
after after xc6 white is thinking young
pony actually that is but at this point
he had a crushing move
that is rook to c3
now the lines in this are just simply
wild
d4 makes the most sense to me attack the
rook as soon as possible open uh things
up and try to get the e5 pawn this is
the key for black so what happens after
d4
rooks
what about the rooks let's go to
checkmate you e6
what boss chair
do you want to take my rook shirt take
my rook now the idea is i take on f7 now
if you go to h8 and allow me to
recapture the rook i'm going to
recapture follow it up with g6 you're
lost yeah so you have to take it and now
comes the killing blow the killing idea
that is hidden to the naked eye and that
is queen to c7 check if you go on the
eighth rank after f6 you get checkmated
wow there's no way to defend the g7
square despite the fact that you are a
rook up
so you have to go look to es7
rook to e7 now i just simply take a rook
followed by g6 this is over right i'm
getting to your king it's pretty much
game over so
wild idea this queen to c7 such a hidden
spot for the queen you're only looking
on this side you're looking at
supporting the move g6 picking up the
bishop breaking through on this side but
not with queen to c7 followed by f6
wild stuff and what if he doesn't go uh
at d4 what else can he do in this
position right so let's say e2
let's say you go uh d4 and after e6 you
take right
now you go f6
once again i'm threatening the move f7
increasing a7 yeah if you take queen f7
or queen to c7 once again the same idea
queen this is the gross ideas as you're
saying i was saying it's inspired it's
an incredible idea yeah but you just
simply don't look at it no no no no no
no it's impressive you don't even start
you're looking at g6 you're not looking
at f6 to couple it with the queen going
through you know what the move rook c3
does
it defends
i could go rook b3 if i was going to
play rook c3 it would be because i saw
d4 rook b3 exactly yeah not because i
saw rook c3d4 and then that's exactly
right but
yeah wow the the combination of e6 and
queen c7 oh my god it was still not over
but right after queen e2 rook to e3 now
sure you're going to give me a check i
go back and g6 f6 e6 are still coming in
the position now your queen is ready to
get trapped as well that is the problem
right your bishop was the problem up to
this point right bishop to f3 is coming
and i'm picking up your queen right it's
remarkable it's just a wild position and
uh the details of the position are so
inspiring and this idea with queen to c7
just blind spots in the position that
blind spot on c7 he did not see it he
played the natural move e6 and right now
after f takes e6
sam was giving him 90
chances of winning this one but if you
don't see rook to c3 i'm not seeing uh
that high of a percentage to win for
white i understand you're going to go g6
you can start with rook to b1 i am
taking a lot of pawns in the meantime
and if i manage to find the safe haven
for my king
then i'm going to be just fine i think
exactly we'll continue with the
g6 uh for just a second
like you said you're taking a lot of
pawns i'm going to continue taking it
let's go rook be one
more or less rupee one first we're gonna
be one now yeah i wrote me one now i
mean i want i want that pawn on b7 queen
35 and i take on yeah
and i take that guy downstairs yeah
and take that guy
i'm taking a lot you only have one pawn
left that is the it's sort of like is it
mating bishop h3 bishop to h3 i mean
you're kidding
seems like it's mate i go here
king
up the board king up the board and i get
it you you're very close but i'm going
to hide on the dark squares this is the
key in this position i'm going to place
all my pieces on dark squares and then
i'm just going to run around it so yeah
checkers you take i go to f6 checkers
exactly king to e5 king
but i i appreciate the fact that i only
have a pawn i'm glad i do
but i really thought that somehow with
the two bishop
pardon me with the two rooks of the
bishop and a king
i would get some mating it's still
within winning margins but jan has to be
very careful right now um okay thank you
thank you thank you very much christian
wow let's go to the alireza's game
because things are happening uh yeah
there is a blunder percolating i can say
it says hey well this was actually uh
a a mention of uh sam shanklin that uh
your bishop on g2 you might want to bail
oh this he first of all he started with
the bishop
yes all good bishop g5
now takes takes h6 get out of here
knight dropped back now because the pawn
on e5 is hanging he dropped back with
his knight which
it's a kind of a fail right because you
you had this open rook right now you
kind of shut yourself off on the other
hand it's kind of a difficult position i
think for white still well exactly if
you can uh
more or less just maintain right the
bishops
yeah that black will do
but okay
so ali razor said let me do it now
where's the bonder what happens if you
go
f5 f5
wow
f5
that's
i didn't even think of it as being legal
for a moment okay so i'll fall for it
let's go bishop take 28.
i didn't see that one
okay
uh so i've got a pawn
an anchor bishop a lot of light squares
you have to be cold-blooded to do this
kind of thing don't you uh okay i'm
hitting the rug
can i
you've got
an exchange for a pawn
yes but i am also coming at some point
with 97 or 94 right
and just
kicking me back now did i do something
wrong uh christian help me out here he
he
you you inspired
alejandro with that line that you showed
with man sees everything what can i uh
what can i say yeah f5 is a good move
and f5 actually gives black a precise
ball advantage not only that
but ali reza is down to his left 11
minutes
11 minutes
on the clock like right now even if you
objectively don't get an advantage after
f5 you still play f5 just to uh create
some imbalances in the position because
with only 11 minutes and no increment
for the next
17 moves
20 moves never never mind i mean we're
at move 21 right now so 19 moves
it's just simply crazy uh not to play
the move f5 you have to look at the
position you calculate for a little bit
you still have
55 minutes as fabiano caruana
and you have his number it does feel
like fabi has alibreza's number not only
in the grand seas but i think he beat
him tata still in tata steel as well
so in the classical matches that they
have uh in which they have met except
bucharest
a couple of months ago
he won most of the encounters
but still two wins and four draws that's
that's pretty good yeah i i mean no
seriously uh
the problem i have with f5
is that i might consider that with the
move queen d6 i have a nice stable
advantage
but do you cause the material is getting
very limited i'm not sure if there's any
more and this is why i think he played
rook takes d7 right he panicked he wants
to exchange as many pieces as possible
he wants to get closer to a position
that he knows it's a technical draw well
here i
again i think i have a nice stable
advantage as black because in my mind i
have the open file open default again i
feel that the queen is offside just
simply if you don't make me what are you
doing i made you
what no i'm not going to play h4 there's
no way but if you don't make me
what no don't go g4 knight h4 yeah well
knight h4 well i mean
great i mean but it's like just one one
dimensional right rook d8 knight f5
queen
here let's go
i'm going to come down i got this white
white why are you got rook t1
that's the whole point right i'm like oh
no i just returned to equality as long
as i'm only playing for equality i think
what it is no but let's try to make some
better moves yeah let's try knight to d4
that's that's much better the knight of
five anyway but then i exchange but this
is what i'm saying that's why you're a
stable advantage
that's fine i mean i'm
defending um yeah no i'm saying that
that my problem
in fabi's shoes
is that i might think that after bishop
h3 queen d6 i'm slightly better
and iced
yeah i stopped there yeah right i don't
necessarily give f7
f5 the full consideration it deserves
now did i do something wrong against
alejandro when he played the move f5
christian no no no
f5 is great no should i have his play f5
is giving black a stable advantage
bishop takes f5 queen to e8 this seems
to be uh the best path forward for both
sides queen to d4 rook to d8 and we play
we play this position white is going to
go rook to c1 nothing is happening
immediately and still white has
uh some compensation the light squares
are his right now so black is going to
try to somehow maneuver around the
bishop on five and capture it at some
point either with knight to e7 or knight
to d4 it does seem like knight to d4 at
least to my
eyes will be the follow up but still
remains a complex battle you have to be
careful not to allow queen to g6 if you
allow that battery next to your king
you're going to get checkmated so
there's still things that black needs to
worry about nevertheless it's an
imbalanced position i am on exchange up
and i don't have
any visible weaknesses right right in
the position as black so we're just
going to play a long game and i'm going
to have the advantage and you're not
going to have any time to make your
decisions this is the big problem right
now for ali reza this is a huge moment
it's a trend though for ali reza right
he's been in time trouble whenever he
has this uncomfortable situations
against nepo
and it does seem like in this one he
played something new something
enterprising this queen to d3 but he was
not very much comfortable and aware of
what he has to do after that and fabiano
immediately surprised him he probably
knew that b6 is the main line
and i'm talking all the way here right
he knew that b6 is likely the main line
but he was like i'm sure he has
something ready in that variation let's
try to equalize let's try to make things
difficult from a practical perspective
against ali reza and let's play c5 i
think that was a good decision by
fabiano and uh definitely threw a wrench
at alireza's bike
so difficult to wrong foot uh fabi
remind remind us a christian about the
clocks and what challenges
uh alireza is facing with the time
control 11 minutes
for how many moves 19 moves
that's a lot of moves that's time
trouble we were talking about into huge
time trouble that huge feel that feels
like you start you you're nervous you're
now in really nervous territory you
think something's mmm
think about it this way guys let's make
a comparison with the situation
that hikaru had yesterday against nepo
and the world champion magnus carlson
looked at the position in which hikaru
still had i think it was definitely less
than 19 moves i think it was around 12
moves to make with a better position
he was better and magnus said that nepo
should have played on
because
he said you have to be a shark in this
type of situations i'm not going to use
the expletive uh language that
the world champion actually used but he
said you have to be a shark right and
you have to continue the game you have
to find the imbalance
in the position uh right now the
imbalance is in front of your eyes just
play the move f5 follow it up with queen
to ea and let's play a game 11 minutes
to go this is in my opinion a very very
difficult situation for the young
frenchman
he's getting into a lot of time trouble
as uh ali reza it doesn't feel like he's
comfortable with the time control right
it's not something that he's known for
to just spending all his time but he's
doing it over and over again in madrid
yeah
and i saw in bucharest too that he was
boring and burning a lot of clock
as well
so i don't know if it's a thing that
crept into his play just wanted
because the game has exploded between
hikaru before we go on break
when we left it
guess what rook g3 that was the move
that we were looking at almost
exclusively d3 on the board rook e1
queen takes b5 i was more you you kind
of threw a wrench at me with the move
queen c2 you could you know you're a
party pooper right i i have to i have
told you that uh but queen c2 was a kind
of move that threw me off queen takes
b5 inviting bishop takes h6 queen h5
you got to play
bishop takes h6 and now i think
ding is ready at long last for d2 what
do you think of them apples
if i don't get mated right right
d2 i think i'm moving the rook
if i move the rook
yeah i i've got bishop takes h6 as a
yeah we should take g7 well pardon me
bishop takes g7 bishop h6 takes g7 and i
can say this sorry
i don't find this clear at all
yeah i mean are you are you getting on
your tennis shoes no
in this case i got queen h a check
that's pretty nice for white right
so what is your d2 on the board
what is your real threat
it's white yes right and we have d2
already rook d1 as well what is it what
is white's
threat here maybe king h2 just to make
sure that whenever you go queen takes d1
or when you promote
uh you're not promoting with check
because if
if i could play king h2 and i know it's
ridiculously slow but if i could play
king h2 and even f4
then i can play rook takes g7 or bishop
takes g7 and you're not playing queen
takes e5 yeah that's a saving grace like
let's make some stupid moves like c5
exactly just to show why bishop takes
yeah i'm just so happy to checkmate you
right here and i got you mated no i
yeah what don't
spoiler yeah exactly yeah so
uh
yeah king h2 f4 and then one day right
so this is a double
31 minutes for hikaru 26 for dingler and
31 for your car 26 for how many moves
six oh yeah that's no problem they'll
make that easily we're gonna take a
quick break alejandro yeah we're going
to leave you with some yasseris some
some yasser stories as we go on a short
break f5 played by fabiano we'll come
back to analyze that game in just a few
[Music]
so this story uh that i'd like to share
is the downside
of analyzing with a chess genius i got
tons of bobby fischer stories and this
one comes courtesy of robert byrne and
robert
tells me the story of the havana
chess olympiad 1966
where he's playing on the american team
and the american team is being led by
none other than
robert james fisher bobby was the only
one on the team who had a suite in the
evenings the whole team would
congregate together at bobby's suite and
they'd replay
the games that they just played that
afternoon in the olympiad robert was
saying this was really the highlight of
the olympiad and everybody on the team
would scramble to get to bobby sweet
because bobby
would show the game he played and
analyze and explain
what was going on these lectures these
moments
were just
absolutely absolutely awesome so bobby
is showing a game that he had played
that day
somewhere as bobby is moving the pieces
and explaining
he then in a derogatory way
calls his opponent a pizza and he goes
and the pizza
played this move and as he's making the
move
bobby starts chuckling
and laughing and then kind of laughing
really really hard the kind of painful
goblin
he literally falls off his chair on the
carpet going back and forth rithering an
absolute
joyous abandonment
laughter about his opponent's moves the
five grand masters on the team
are looking at the position because the
pizza
played a reasonable move
and they couldn't understand why bobby
was laughing nobody saw the reputation
and
robert was in a panic
an absolute stone cold
panic
because
he's laughing and robert doesn't see why
bobby's so
so incredulous about isabella
then
bob sees the reputation of the book and
bob starts laughing
and then collectively around the table
all five see the move
bobby who's now in tears just barely
makes it back to the table and makes the
move
that robert byrne anticipated and boom
boom boom and bingo bongo so robert
tells me the story decades later
that he was an abject terror
he would not have seen the move
and that bobby would realize that
nobody's seeing the move and kick
everybody out and think of them as
potzers too and robert did not want
bobby fischer thinking he was a weak
player so the moment he saw that winning
move he said
the relief that i felt
was almost the taste of honey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody it is round six
and the round has exploded these are the
standings they will not be the standings
in about a minute so let's get out of
this because we have to go straight into
the games the games are absolutely
exploding we have to go to the netball
game against john shisht of duda that is
definitely the game of the round but a
lot of other stuff has happened as well
yes as we expect at least one result
very soon but we have to start here
first absolutely shout out to sam
shanklin sam said well man if i'm in
nepo shoes i'm playing e6 and i think
it's a 90 chance
that nepo is going to win the game he
did he sacrificed
the pawn on e6 he sacrificed the pawn on
f5 but he picks up the bishop on h7 with
a check black tries to play the move uh
um king h8 to use the pawn on h7 as a
shield but this was the problem is that
the rook was breaking into black's camp
rook to b1 takes b7
and this move rook takes a h5 if i mean
rook takes f5 that's a visual you can't
take the rook queen takes g7 as mate
check king back rook takes
well you know like everything looks like
it's it's it's it's disappearing uh rook
f7
check bishop back
d4 and then this move really
uh clears the cop webs if you thought i
was going to play rook f8 check and try
to put my bishop on d3 and meet your
king
rook comes to g5 rook takes g7 and rook
g8
is what's on eon's menu and it looks
game over i don't see a defense no i
don't either it does seem like the only
defense might be to go rook to e8 and
also that's a hidden resource rook to
each e8 right how would the game
continue so if you do take on g7 i take
on f1
and now that my rook is on an open file
i will be able to penetrate via the e2
square so i go queen to c1 if you take
with the king
and then rook to e2 if you go king g2 or
nasty uh so rook e8 is a hidden defense
yes ah
but of course i don't have to take on g7
right no i can just simply go i don't
know queen to f4 for example
keeping f1 and not only that but i also
threatened to go cafe
i think you're uh
close to being busted i see i see so
that's one secondly uh in the game
between hikaru and nakamura and ding
lyrin a really really tight fight all
the way through
we got to this position we just saw d2
we went on break rook came to d5
and then in this position after the move
rook d5 car went into the tank
said i'm bailing out yeah i've got to
take on g7 you might really have to at
this point exactly and he did he took on
g7 and after this four sequence he's
going to end up giving a series of
perpetual checks
and we expect the king to drop back
there is a nice trap
it's a nice it's like take my queen
king d7 play the move e6 check and win
my queen with a discovery well
the tables could cur
could turn in this in this case but you
don't take the queen you go queen takes
f7 check and you win the rook and this
is actually winning for
ikaru but i think that well we were
analyzing this on our break in our minds
without an engine right and i'm kind of
revisiting that what happens if i go
king we're playing king c8 and it ended
up losing because king c8 queen takes d5
we realized was very strong for white
correct but what happens if i go up
i want to get to the same position that
we wanted to get before but you want the
rook on d e5 alive alive instead of
allowing me to take i'll take the rook
on e8 check back to b7 now you'll be
less frisky
okay but do you have a threat right now
so what if i go queen h5 maybe
um
even i'm
wondering
can i be greedy and
well here maybe i shouldn't have done
what i did but
you said queen h5
just to defend that rook on d1 and go
maybe queen f3 next move or something
like that understood
it's fair
now the question is can we take on e4 i
can take on e5 you have to play queen f3
rook takes two doesn't work does it or
it doesn't work no you can't
yeah so rook takes e5 does work and i
will have to play queen f3 check
although here i could make an argument
that i'd rather be black
yeah if i if i have to be given a choice
right i mean i do might so let's try to
find something better right my passer so
right here after king b7 i wasn't sure
why i had to panic at all
maybe here i can go king h2
and be prepared to meet rook takes one
e5 with um queen c1 it's not uh it's not
the end of the world right no of course
not and rook takes e5 what do you do if
i do this well queen e5 is at least a
perpetrator well not more than that but
it is definitely you do get the
perpetual thank goodness for that
i could bail out but we are seeing a
perpetual check i don't think we're
going to be seeing the king d7 king c6
variation
and let's jump to fobbies because if
bobby when we left he did play this
um
i'm going to exchange up move f7 f5
and here while we we understood bishop
takes
f5 queen e8 queen g4
would lead to an advantage for black
uh
helping farouza
captured with the pawn
and after rookie eight night push and
we're just quickly just trying
just a moment a moment of
of calm reflection queen takes a2 gotta
love it uh rook f7 knight f4 and
continue to tune this is the current
position on the board uh
that we caught up with the players we
did move 29 uh eight minutes for alireza
edmonds 39 and fabiano carona has 21
minutes meanwhile the hikaru game has
officially finished in the draw that we
expected
and this is the current situation on the
board for favi who is
well let's just face it he's up on
exchange and
the move right rook d8 just played yes
baffles me a little bit and why am i
giving up the pawn right but
i was going to say that even despite
this he is stopping material
even after he gave
i
i
was being told is the best move so there
must be some kind of trap i'm missing
maybe rook can come to
c2
in this particular case well that is
pretty yeah that's pretty pertinent in
action
queen takes p2
d8 is hanging so just a second so oh
where where do you put the queen i was
going to put the king on
h3 but then er
this could be uh
danger danger will robinson um
well that's a problem that looks
crushing
wow i mean queen b2 looks like such a
strong threat
exactly knight g5 queen b2
holy smokes and this is we do have f
takes e3
on the board already
so we could be looking at rook
and what
holy smokes what
wha what a win this would be because we
were speaking
as early as the first broadcast what are
the winning scores what's it going to
take to win how do you get to a victory
we know you don't get to a victory with
two losses we were we were thinking that
that was like the hardest path to the
victory yeah only you could lose one
game right but not two ali reza ferrugia
currently in last place now we lost one
game yeah we already have one result
there seeker nakamura and digler and did
play their game and finished it whereas
alirez and timor are still playing but
ali reza's position looks crushed right
would he be at the bottom of the table
six rounds into this tournament
no wins
two losses
and essentially out of it i mean i mean
that's kind of hard to believe that you
can if he had even anything as much as
five percent chances i
i i would be shocked uh jumping again
back to nepal versus duda he did not
find the hidden resources of rookies he
said he played the move queen d6
we do have a result uh it does seem like
timor raj above drew his game against
richie rapport what when we came back
from uh the break i i looked at the
engine and the engine was saying that
rajabov was actually winning
and i was completely shocked right now
it just finished out out of a sudden now
let's see what happened here
it was this uh position rook takes h4
was played which apparently gives white
a tremendous advantage king to g1 rook
to e4
and now
for the draw he could have played bishop
h2 was actually
just winning
well yeah how do you defend your fish
that is a very good question
and if you go bishop to aa then
that's a problem so you have to stop the
action of the bishop first with e5 but
you simply run out of time you just
don't have squares for the bishop no
squares for the bishop
this is over bishop was a huge
opportunity very easy
how much time did he have rook to f7 he
had four minutes
and he played it almost instantaneously
um but with only two moves to go this is
move 38
you might as well start thinking about
wait wait a minute his position looks
very hot
this bishop on b7 if i manage to get the
rook on the seventh rank is going to be
dead so how do i do that
to h2 not only that but it does seem
like if you go c5 rook to f7 rook to b4
maybe this is what he missed that
there's another square to give a check
from look to c7 pick up the bishop maybe
this is
what he missed
inexplicable to me why he did not stop
and think play the move rook to f7
and now we just have the trade-off and
this is just going to be
he
is a perpetrator
dude
i gotta say i mean he's really been
pushing his luck and he got away with
juan today because really we were coming
back and we were thinking actually
that uh
you know timor is so tough when you when
you push him against a wall and you say
you got to play really really really
well well look at how many pawns he
sacrificed got into those bishops of
opposite color position
and he was taking over the game we
like
like we're saying we came back we
expected bishop h2 we did not see it
for richie
and then the fact that you just said the
game is a draw uh shocked us yeah yeah
but this is just a testament of his
mentality rajabov that is he saw rook to
f7 he saw that he can force a draw and
maybe he just went for it he didn't even
sit down and he did not could be better
no
he did not consider his position that
even in a million years he could be
better wow that's a mistake
so two draws
in the books we've got two games
remaining we're expecting
queen f2 played by nepo which i think
just finishes the game exactly uh we're
expecting that rook takes g7 and rook g8
will just finish the game
uh black's king is frankly uh
well
yeah
the bishop is doing a great job
protecting as are the white rooks by the
way the white rooks are stopping any
kinds of checks from the front the
bishop stopping checks from behind rook
takes
rook f7 takes g7 followed by rook g8 as
a simple winning threat no defense
and for yon
uh pinch me once once more i i i i
it's a dream come true plus three out of
six rounds with a crush everybody's
so much and that leaves us very
importantly with the fobby game because
if fabi wins it becomes a two horse race
it is a two horse race right now because
fabiano is winning this one really
they're going straight into the
variation that we looked at with rook to
c7 and knight to f7 and fabi is looking
tremendously
well in that one and check this out jan
is going to go to four and a half out of
six and fabiano is going to be closely
behind only half a point at four out of
six if he manages to convert his
decisive advantage and fabi will have
separated himself from the third place
ikaru and richie by a full point and
jani is going to be a point and a half
ahead of everybody else but
those two those two players
will and that's definitely
as
sam was saying you take those two
players against the field and i think
it's now is the case that you take the
two players
with their plus three and plus two what
a bold statement
that's why you get the big bucks that's
right knight f7 how bad is it uh jump
right in christian and just tell us that
it's really bad it's resignable bad for
yourself resign
yes that's very bad the only way to
continue apparently is queen to d1 okay
but that's just awesome but this is
resignable yeah yeah you take take the
king is actually out of play and i'm
just going to target the pawn you don't
have the move e4 because of knight to g5
picking up
that's a problem you have to go here and
knight to e5 i can start attacking this
pawn first with rook to b5 it's just a
hopeless end game hopelessly
and by the way fearucha is down to his
last three minutes oh
my but what a
sometimes you feel that a player
is frustrated over the board i'll i'll
show you what happened alejandro please
check this position out
one hour and 33 minutes yeah knight to
d2 he spent 40 minutes on this move
how can you spend 40 minutes on such a
natural move knight to d2 just played
you are not allowed in this type of
tournament to live yourself with 10
minutes when you get to this position
rook takes d7 and it becomes extremely
complicated and imbalanced right you
cannot spend 40 minutes or knight to d2
which anything could have worked knight
c3 would have word e4 any any of the
other moves right you don't spend 40
minutes on that decision and then leave
yourself with 10 minutes for this wild
complicated mess
it's just
not practical bad time management and
it's uh it's frustrating not only
ali reza
today but in the past viktor korchnoy
and many other great players
bad time management will cost you many
half points and full points so after
this move king h3 yeah we had to move
knight f7 and bishop f3 played by
alireza not the queen d1
that
we thought was going to be played and i
think we were looking at moves like rook
here intending knight g5 check as well i
think we just didn't see a a defense
yeah you probably also have a choice of
wins at this point right you are up in
exchange the king is on h3 you can
imagine knight g5 probably win somehow
sure i can imagine trying to pick up the
f5 pawn win somehow
yeah like if the end game is really that
bad you can consider even a move like
queen c2
it's perhaps not the most direct but
it looks
darn good i mean the end game is so
winning right any queen yeah exactly any
queen trades uh you start to think uh i
was
forgive me i was i was playing more
direct right which might be the easiest
that might be the easiest
uh well it could be the easiest to
calculate
right i mean
if you can uh play rook c2 queen takes
rook takes h2 there is a mate
happening knight e5 could be just uh
hakimati uh
after the move uh bishop f3 um
christian
uh which is the most clean cut let's get
out of here kind of rook c5
what a rook c5
rook so the same idea attacking the pawn
on f5 trying to create some uh more
weaknesses in the meantime if you go e4
try defending like that now i can force
the trade no questions
as well as the night for the bishop guys
by the way it is officially over janna
pognac has won against yanshi of dura he
currently sits
way far ahead of the field wow as only
fabi really has a chance
to put pressure on nepo
huge victory for uh
big big big uh loss for duda fans i mean
because he's knocking down a rival as
well
with this victory for the intrigue of
the tournament and just because of that
reason i'm very happy that alireza is
not winning today imagine that laressa
wins today against favi tournaments
done
that was a point
earlier in the tournament and
almost ready to lap the field right yeah
i remember one world championship at the
time that it wasn't the candidates it
was the world championship in san luis
argentina it's a eight player double
round robin just as we're seeing now and
there was one vessel in topolof in the
event and i'm thinking i if i remember
it correctly he went six out of seven
something like that right for the first
half and it was like do we need a second
half
he coasted his way home
to victory and became world champion but
for nepo
tip of the hat well done nepo a nepo a
has certainly shown up and what a way to
start the tournament for the challenger
of the previous world championship this
is just amazing chess by him destroys
judah from just a knight f3 g3 variation
nothing special exactly got him to a a
nice position and took the game fabiana
caron is the only one that has any
chances left to score a full point today
because i think alvarez is just dead
and we expect him to get up to four
points
which means at least he's giving chase
he's a half a point behind and
well from
fabi's point of view it says like
we are doing very well aren't we john
this is great news for both of us um
i don't know about you but i was
intrigued by what um
christian said that you first play rook
c5
in order to play rook take because i was
asking what's the
cleanest cleanest win you go rook takes
a and if you provoked the move after
rook c5 e4
well then you go for those queen trades
with knight g5 check and queen takes f3
and you go
as fast as you can
into that very ending that's very easily
winning for
and uh
compounding his problem is that uh for
for ali reza he has only has
he currently has two minutes and 46
seconds for seven moves fabi is down to
his last 13 but that seems to be plenty
here right
did rook c5 was that the first move on
your raider not at all i think rook c5
you you you kind of visit because bishop
d5 could be annoying if it was white to
move exactly your first instinct is okay
i got to stop my opponent's threat but
then when you think about the fact that
you have stronger threats than he does
i've got threats i got threats too then
you think okay i don't have to worry
about bishop d5 i'll go rook c2 right
away right and then i would just stop
there exactly and another bit of a
hidden motive behind this idea of rook 2
c5 is that if you do go g4 which makes a
lot of sense right sure we know that e4
doesn't really defend it does defend but
it allows knight g5 that's just a game
over so you have to play the move g4 now
once you open the third rank i have
ideas of potentially after queen to d1
to just simply take on e3 okay and
transition into this winning position
because
i take your king is not only getting uh
checkmated but i'm just simply picking
up your knight on f4 so you're
completely lost quite an interesting uh
and um engaging idea with rook to c5
and by the way
the best move right now for white
apparently it's like bishop to g2 or
bishop to h1
it doesn't make any sense
if he finds rook to c5
practically the game will be over
conversely if he plays what to my eyes
is very natural rook c2 uh christian
yeah that's compelling as well
they take the pawn on b2 right right
bishop to d yeah this is this is not
much i mean you're going to take on
h2 king here and now rook to d2 is one
way i would assume you can return with
the queen to f6 that's another
you don't have too many problems that
you have to worry about just not allow
some sort of queen d a knight g6
configuration to give you a checkmate if
you don't allow that you're just simply
winning exactly well i mean just this
idea of picking up the pawn on b2
picking up upon on h2 with check
yeah i like taking the f5 pawn as well
but
that would be really attractive to me
but i like what you said um oftentimes
uh i'm there to be a party pooper my
opponent wants a threat my opponent he
just played the move bishop g4 what are
you trying to do with this move bishop
g4 you're trying to play
pardon me bishop e4 and f3 you're trying
to play bishop to d5 so what am i trying
to do stop you from realizing
uh your objective and therefore rook c5
uh
yeah yeah that merits a good uh
consideration i agree
joyce of riches i think i think it is
bobby i i think for us we're kind of
like
we're still recovering from the blow of
watching all of these draws 11 draws out
of the last 12 games and then seeing
nepo being the one okay i'll take
another point
yep that's mine
i'll dip
so we're just like watching him waltz
away
with the tournament by the way gabby did
play rook seats i think we're going down
that line because queen d1 was played as
well not a lot of choices there foreign
excuse me rook c2 was uh
um
yeah fabi
and fabi calculating
knight g5 check blade knight g5 check i
assume you play it to g4
not much of a choice on that line
but there was
this is where
where where um
christian was saying well one of the
things you don't want to do or don't
want to allow us queen d8 checks and uh
have white get into your business uh
what's going on now he has everything
under control knight except three came
on the board like how do you get there
that's the problem you don't get there
so you can go start with queen d8 right
right 28 king h7 what do you do next and
this is not checkmate because
well first of all i have 95.
that is the worst case scenario right
right do i have the best to have a
better case scenario
i don't like my worst case scenario that
much
there has to be a better case scenario
this is what i would say
is where you go wrong right okay i i
don't want to do that so okay c4
queen to c4
ah there's a knight g1 oh knight g5
so you have to take and now i go quinitu
uh-huh
and then i go rook c4 whatever you
do and then i think yeah yeah
now we're warming up with your christian
yeah
you're picking up okay yeah yeah yeah
you got the cookies uh
you got the goods
all right so knight takes f3 by the way
queen d8 check king h7 and he the coin
f3 not knight g6 but he did take on f3
all right and i i like that line that
you just showed how do we get to it can
we can we get there
some other way now
so
he's actually taking on b2 the fearless
fabian
that takes somebody to take on b2 knight
to g6 right you have to otherwise queen
takes b well knight to e6 is also worth
uh consider considering ah queen e6 but
i think they must fall to the same sword
right whatever it is whether it be
knight g6 or knight e6 let's just see
okay
that's my only check in the position
let's go check
that must get mated by h5 right
because you cannot go to g5
because of queen to f6 right that's game
over that should be game over
yeah also
sorry
after h5 king g5 right
queen f6 exchanging the queens yeah
that's just the amount
now any queen trade oh instantly uh
winning for black but let's update guys
let's let's update the game because he
played queen eight well we do have queen
takes b2 queen e8 and we are updated we
we've caught up with the players
at this moment there is a move that kind
of screams to be played queen f6 yeah i
i guess right
without f6 and i think the only defense
for black is to go
the reason it might is if i can ever i
don't know get it
nah okay it doesn't matter i i agree i
agree queen f6 stop e4 is the only move
yeah because i'm throwing queen c6 here
right
yes that's a big threat as well as queen
takes f5 so you have to play e4 okay and
then i've got
i got what
i can play rook c3 check right you'll
probably have to go to g2
and maybe not about playing c6
queen c6 anyway queen c6 anyway
yeah that might do it i just want to
keep uh
kick the queen off of the eighth rank
that makes sense you got queen f7 and
have this important move uh
well queen f7 i think i can go rook c3
queen takes c4 and i think i'm
checkmating you
and you're not you don't actually have a
perpetual for example king g4
queen takes e4
you have f6
wait a minute
i don't want to get myself in trouble
well uh you did
it's too late you did
is it till later okay let's try
something else why it was too late but
okay
i think it's time to
well queen f6 hmm
okay queen f6 is played e4 is going to
come
fast
okay can you start with rook c3
oh that makes a lot more sense e4 has
been played again i apologize rook c3
first the the the time oh sorry the
times we got a minute and 24 for lyreza
and fabiano corona has seven minutes
uh it only has to make four yeah for
seven one you only have one more one
one move that's fine
and
well roxy three actually does look
pretty compelling okay yeah well what
about rook c3 shack
i'm assuming the king is dropping back
to g2 and then go between c6 and now
queen c6 yeah now that's a totally
different tickle right so what if you go
to g4
what what what and and provoke queen g5
check sure i mean
at this point i don't have a lot of
options that is true that is true you
want me to fall for queen takes f4 don't
take on that yeah that's my only chance
i guess
that i always like that expression
snatching
uh defeat from the jaws of victory
uh
well it doesn't have an immediate
refutation that's easy
rook 33 knight g6 queen takes f5 nice
find yasser no it was not me truly it's
not i mean i i i'm sitting here next to
alejandro who inspires me each and every
day
to greater heights
i do my best
take the pawn yes sir i hear this
whisper in my i mean that's nice queen
of five is made by one queen h5
by the way uh
not exactly made but it's really good
it's pretty good right
i'll take the queen yeah yeah that's a
nice one yeah
so in fact you actually don't have a
threat
in that position you just simply don't
have a threat because knight g6 is
always queen h5 exactly yeah exactly
yeah but we are thinking that the most
precise at this moment by the way that's
another thing that i do like about uh
bobby's chess
is that he
i wasn't going to say
he
he usually finds the cleanest win
if you give him a winning position he'll
be clinical you'll be clinical he's very
good about it but he took the book he
thinks that the clinical version in this
game is to just
hose the bond take the bond it's free
why not so the main question is what if
knight g6 is amazing assume it's cc3 and
that is actually
going to end up getting white mated and
with the recon h2 i have h5 yeah with
the rook on h2 h5 is
an added bonus i would say yeah and you
just end up made it right so get into f4
rook f2 king g4
queen h
queen f3 i thought h5 also works oh no
queen f3 just wins on the spot but queen
f3 i think it's just easy
yep king h4 rook h2 king h3 queen h5
yeah this is over king h3 queen h5 again
that
somehow uh we reach this position down
to his last 20 seconds guys 20 seconds
reza he needs to make a move before time
control but at this point it just does
not matter
nope i think it's over i mean
the use of his problems is the clock
time
i'm just going to refresh my board
apologies for play the move queen d7 to
make time control
yeah okay that that actually doesn't
help too much it actually destroys its
own threats right like i just just don't
have a threat at the moment right
and every move wins
yeah queen
yeah again i'm looking for the most
surgical absolute let's go
uh it does strike me that the the the
check meeting patterns that you guys
were showing me just a moment ago with
queen shaq and rook
uh
i'll tell you what the easiest is please
queen c3 followed by queen d2
forces the queen trade
because i have queen that that i like a
lot yeah that's the end right i mean
that is exactly what i was looking for
thank you christian queen
c3 check king
g4 queen d2 forcing the trade of queens
thanks to the threat of queen takes uh
queen d1 and your e-pawn is not going
anywhere no no no no no no no
if i want to with my rook if i want to
it's not going anywhere yeah even the
king is in the square of the past e pawn
so i love that uh
for me that's a very human way of
collecting the point
that's the easiest yeah and if you do
have some other
wonderfully complex wins well you know
mazel tov
and after queen d2 you also cannot go
knight to d5 to try to create some sort
of threats because of h5 checkmate
almost well what i mean almost well king
f3 and rook f2 evergreen yeah
wow that's the easiest
um coming into today and you're you know
you would ask me you know like what
would be the results what would be the
expected results uh somehow the two
leaders both winning
and timor winning would not have been on
my list and that turns out to have been
what maybe should have happened should
have happened didn't happen right
timor again he was too um quick
to make a perpetual check if he had just
paused moved his bishop he could have he
could have won against richie and really
crushed
richie's hopes actually everybody's
hopes are fading fast
yeah i mean some of these players even
though they haven't lost the game it
does feel like they're drawing
themselves out of the tournament
currently that applies mostly to richard
he has six out of six draws which means
point and a half away he has 50 as well
having drawn uh
not as many games but he did lose
against fabi right beating uh timor and
the people on minus one man they are
really far away from nepal right now
right he's just
what about the alireza who's going to be
on minus two
yeah this is another we're just yelling
him out at this point right he's out
right yeah
can we still count him in no i don't
think so two and a half points away two
and a half that's too many
in here is how you win a tournament
she says what a line scorer that is just
gorgeous
plus three for yan nepal niantic
defeated plus three undefeated plus
three winning against dingley run
well his score is definitely not three
his score is four and a half no score is
plus three yes
yes but again if if i'm in nepo shoes
and i'm saying my desired target score
is nine
and i'm sitting there with four and a
half out of six
sorry the thing maybe
yeah i pushed that bar a little higher
you know i give myself a challenge uh
but what an a a very very impressive
performance tongue-in-cheek
anishigiri said
nepo is our future well the future of
chess
i think he
might be something about it right right
wow
wow uh christian uh
uh we're kind of thrown back over here
we're stunned by the developments it's
it's incredible it's very reminiscent
once again i'm going to bring the same
point that i brought a couple of days
ago
it reminds me of vishyana in 2014
2013 he loses against magnus carlsen the
world champion
ship and then he goes on and kills the
candidates kills 2014. absolutely no
chance i think karjakin was within
striking distance in the last round but
that was only if like vichy was losing
and karjakin was winning pretty much no
chance right right so
this is exactly what i'm saying right
now for from nepal nevertheless
and this is where sam made a great point
let's wait and see how the second part
of this event
starts because we know nepo slows down
in the world championship match game six
that's the big one game six midpoint
almost through the championship he loses
then and then he just simply collapses
so if he loses one that's when the
questions start arising how is he going
to handle with those type of situations
nevertheless
given the tournament situation right now
we have to take fabiano and nepo at
something along the lines of 80 against
the field wow
even though there are eight more rounds
to go eight count them we've only gone
through six we are still currently on
the sex we are expecting
fabi to
win this game but with eight rounds to
go
it's just because everybody else is
doing so poorly and
you know while nepo winning seems to be
routine for everybody else including
accepting for fabian as well
it's very hard to get a victory out of
all of those players except for fabian
nepo we have one
one win that's hikaru nakamura against
teamwork and that's it that's the whole
field the whole field all of it we do
have the move queen queen
uh was played by the way yeah we did was
play queen a4 instantly replied to uh
assuming even b5 b5 is winning but i i
just don't see a problem with h5
honestly h5 if you go king g5 i think
queen e3 is
over
finito
yeah yep nothing to argue about that one
um
i didn't know if you wanted to take nb
that's actually one of my weaknesses
maybe it's a strength but it's one of my
weaknesses
as a player i love winning tempo and
sometimes you know
obviously i'm thinking i'm going to play
the move queen d1 against anything
except queen a4 so oh you're going to
put your queen on a4 i'll play b5 win at
tempo and then i'll figure maybe h5 guys
guys but also h5 king g5
h5 king g5 yes come on
easier than queen e3 and queenie 28 is
made
queen d8
go back
whoops you don't know you know what kuni
3 was good enough
no no queen e3 i go f6 and my king is
king no
get out of here
it's over guys queen a4
didn't even wait for the reply alireza
frucia has resigned again
wow he didn't wait for h5 just didn't
wait for b5 he didn't wait for anything
i think it was depressing
awful
wow we have a two-horse race we have
incredible
this dude that was to win how would it
affect it yeah because take a look those
were the standings from the previous
round wow this is when round five
finished and let's take a look now at
what happens when
you have just two when you have just two
players right because these are the new
ones right these are the standings after
round six four and a half points plus
three yander pomnyachi is the clear
leader but guess what a certain fabiano
caruana
is there trailing by only half a point
and the rest of the field is looking at
them like they are off on a train and
going away somewhere because whatever
those guys are eating
could i share the menu richard rapport
and hikar nakamura currently tied for a
third with three points that's a full
point and a half away from nepal the
only two players at fifty percent and on
minus one we have janji stuff duda timur
rajabov and dingley ren meanwhile all
the way now down in the cellar
everybody's pre-tournament favorite
wouldn't it be nice if the young men
were to win
nope alirez of russia currently two
points out of six on a minus two score
and definitely not in shape it does not
seem that this will be the candidates
wow and i'm just again
uh when anish giri weighs in check this
out from twitter user and ishkiri
okay nepal playing fire for the double e
championship title and let's call
is a bit tongue-in-cheek of course
remember
that
magnus has made those waves that he
doesn't yes he wants to play
somebody he's already played clear
and i'm just reflecting on i think it
was christian who
mentioned it even though we were also
aware of it
magnus chiming in
when nepal made a draw with ikaro or
rather allowed hikaru to make a
repetition
and
magnus saying
dude
you got to be a shark in these
situations if napo had won yesterday
winning the day
man uh
what a
what an event final thoughts christian
well uh this was just a clarifying round
going into today's round we saw a lot of
players having chances uh to take it all
the way to the bank but after this one
it just feels like it's a two horse race
and let's not bash ali reza too much the
guy is only 19 years of age she has
plenty of chess and plenty of years
ahead of himself unfortunately in this
one i think he's out uh dingli ran needs
to wake up soon because he has his
chances but right now he's drawing his
uh way out of contention and nepo i mean
what can be said against the stellar
player of nepo he just gets the
positions that he wants this is exactly
what happened today he got that
brilliant position with an exciting
attack on the king's side and he made
great use of the dynamic play that was
given to him by duda just an amazing
tournament so far guys and check those
predictions out who's still in the race
who's still in the race
he's still in the race
anyway we'll see you we'll see you
tomorrow we will have the
tomorrow round of the first half of the
candidates yesterday let's stay tomorrow
tomorrow's the rest day thank you thank
you rest day for coming yes exactly but
round seven is coming in two days that
will finish the first half of the
candidates and everybody will have
played each other once right we already
know that two people will be hollers and
then we will flip colors for the second
half no games tomorrow these are the
pairings for round seven richard robert
is going to be playing with white
to keep the tournament alive yeah rich
dude do the field of favor do the field
of favor do yourself a favor right and
blow it open against
me
will play against hikaru nakamura uh
thinly you're in against i mean i did
not expect going into the seventh round
and saying that dingley ran against
alireza perugia seems like an irrelevant
circle that game and said key match-up
number one versus number two fighting
for last place but something that is
definitely going to be catching the
attention of the top spots fabiano
carrano with white
playing as a weekend in my opinion
temurajabo who doesn't seem to be
feeling himself in this tournament
missing this win today
yeah that's hurtful that's hurtful
absolutely thank you everybody for
sharing your day with us i'm sure you'll
agree that the players deserve a rest
day and we'll see you all on saturday
see you then bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited